the left clocks got
9 30 so
we'll start the uh
so for the the folks in attendance and
the millions around the world this is
the subcommittee hearing on house bill
397 in reference to the interstate
compact for the placement of children
the subcommittee is also attended by
children and family laws this is a
substantial part of this
so we've done a we've i've asked for a
joint subcommittee on this and the
chairman of that committee is with us
today
so the gist of this is
the state of new hampshire and
if i butcher this
representative rice absolutely jump in
here is the state of new hampshire has a
compact already for the placement of
children that is clearly not working
so this portion of senate bill 397
addresses the a new compact that is
underway and being formed and
the
bill outlines
the guts of what that compact looks like
we're also
uh here to discuss an amendment that was
brought forward to this that is
extraordinarily necessary to make parts
of this work for us
and i will
open this with chairman rice and she can
talk about
what's going on
so thank you very much so i just wanted
to i think that the compact really
speaks for itself
you know times are changing and evolving
and we need to keep up with those
changes hence the need for a new
compact
i think one of the most important parts
of this is the amendment
that
for lines
12 through 15 especially
that this will help protect
children who are being taken across
straight lines or children coming from
another state
that um
had a case so that we can make sure
they're being put in safe
environments so that we can make sure we
don't have another harmony montgomery
yep
now as uh
for those of you that don't know when it
this is a go or no go situation in
reference to this
we we don't have the ability to modify
the terms of the compact we're either in
or out
so one of the things that we saw during
during the public hearing initially on
house bill 390 or senate bill 397
uh there were some questions in
reference to what happens with the
current compact
in reference to moving into the new
compact and one of the things that was
reiterated is that we don't exit the
current compact until the new compact
it takes effect so it's not going to
leave the state of new hampshire in a
dead zone if you will where we're
outside of a compact
the the the compact in reference here
does have a high threshold of 35 states
that is a substantial
that's about triple honestly of what
most compacts are but because of the
nature of
the topic the situation that we're in
and the fact that the united states
moves children um across state lines
readily
the bar does need to be
at this level
we heard testimony from the oplc in
reference to them supporting
uh the original bill at the time they
were not aware of the
uh
carson amendment
and if uh since i have oplc gut people
here
has your opinion on that changed
no fantastic wonderful
and i we do have john williams who's the
health and human services liaison he's
also here
and everything's still cool with you
guys
yeah all right dcyf as well wonderful
that's great having everyone on board at
this state bureaucracy is
extraordinarily helpful here so that
that also tells me that
we don't have um there shouldn't be any
surprises at least with this part of
this does anybody else in the
subcommittee representative marsh
yes i just want to say that we the
current interstate compact for the
protection of children dates from 1960.
that's when they first started working
on it
about 60 years ago the world has changed
in 60 years and clearly there are issues
that remain to be addressed i am totally
supportive of the state of new hampshire
adopting this compact at this time
because we're not quite at the threshold
where it would come into effect we are
we would be
uh in the group who would be able to
possibly modify the terms of this
compact so there is an advantage to the
state in adopting it at this time i'm
totally on board with uh supporting uh
the amendment uh 0-9-3-2-s i'm not sure
we can adopt the senate amendment as uh
part of the house and because of that
question i did ask ols if nobody else
had drafted this as a house amendment to
do so in my name i have not yet received
sure yeah that's that's fine
representative allegro
um
i just need to be refreshed a little bit
representative rice mentioned that it's
not um working as well as it should the
way it's set up now
could you just um refresh me on
what's different about this
compact versus the old compact and how
absolutely yes i don't need an extensive
thing but
thank you both and please introduce
yourself for the folks on the internet
absolutely good morning joe ripson
director of dcyf
john williams the director of
legislative affairs for the new
hampshire department of health and human
services
thank you very much for the question
happy to happy to try to explain a
little bit further so the current
compact as representative marsh
mentioned um was adopted in 1965. um
obviously the world has changed quite a
bit but specifically the challenges with
the current compact there's there's a
handful of them um
one first and foremost is that in the
close to six years since it's passed
many states have changed certain
provisions or decided that certain
provisions don't apply to them so it's
no longer actually
operating as a uniform compact across
all the states in fact that's one of the
things that happened here in new
hampshire
there's a new hampshire supreme court
case
way that it was drafted did not apply in
new hampshire which is
what um led to it was a case called
alexis oh led to the situation where
you had um the ability or really the
prohibition on doing a home study when
placing a child with a parent out of
state that's what the amendment um seeks
to redress was that specific change
but moreover it doesn't have clarity as
to what types of placements to which it
applies
so it just talks about placing children
out of state but there's not clarity is
that
when a parent sends a child to a
treatment facility on the other on
another state line some states say yes
some states say no does it apply when
child protection gets involved and is
placing a child with a parent across
state lines some states say yes some
states say no
furthermore there's no dispute
resolution process spelled out so if you
have two states who disagree how it's
supposed to operate there's no way to
actually resolve that issue
the new compact addresses all of those
things
creates a new regulatory body as
representative marsh mentioned which
would we would be able to be part of the
initial representative regulatory body
to draft those more specifics um which
is great
and the uh short term amendment that we
seek in here the one that would trigger
immediately and then be repealed when
the full compact passes closes that
loophole that i talked about with the
alexa oh case
you have silenced mr williams that's
amazing
thank you for that that's that's um
that's extraordinarily helpful
as we don't have the terms of the
current compact in front of us
are you good with that mark yeah yeah
okay
perfect
so with that with the the serenation of
a cell phone um
i will i will add that you know we've
unfortunately
we as the government react to things
we try to be proactive but
in a lot of cases it takes an
unfortunate event to really push
something forward and
there is no doubt that's the situation
that we're in right now but i also
think that we are not overreacting or
knee-jerk reacting to that situation
we've this is this has been a problem
that's
been ongoing for a while this is nothing
that has just now happened and i think
that
you know the the situations that have
occurred in in manchester really
um highlight the need for us to
to kind of move this forwards
you know place it on the front burner if
you will so
um with that if there's no other
concerns or questions by anyone
and any and i'm gonna i know it's a
subcommittee hearing but any of my
agency guys everybody's good
then then i will close the subcommittee
hearing on this um mr chairman before
you do that do you want a motion if you
would like representative marsh i think
you know where i would move just so the
subcommittee is on the record that we
move ought to pass with an amendment
that would be the house equivalent of uh
amendment zero nine three two s which we
are yet to get back from okay so from a
procedural standpoint because this
subcommittee hearing only touches on the
child placement section
we could do that for the amendment since
it's specific to that part the whole
bill itself
because it's in two parts we're going to
have to we'll just have to do it as a
whole committee then reward it whatever
you believe appropriate okay so yeah i'm
i would second um
a favorable motion of accepting the
932 s or as it will be
replaced into a house version with the
exact same language
do we have any discussion specifically
on the carson
what is currently known as the carson
amendment
do i need to hold off representative
mcguire for a minute
okay yeah we're just going to take a
vote real quick on the carson amendment
to
just as a subcommittee it'll take a
second
since there's only five of us is any do
we have anyone in opposition
no okay great thank you
perfect yep
perfect thank you very much
you're welcome thank you chairman rice
for attending today
and with that i will close the
subcommittee hearing on senate bill
397 in reference to the child placement
compact
right
morning
it may be 10 o'clock by some clock
so when you're discussing 277 as a
subcommittee
and the amendment which i had
euler's draft is in front of everybody i
think
it's an amendment 2022-1695-h
by myself this is the amendment to the
bill this is the work of
um
uh our work from the previous
subcommittee on this bill so we
incorporated all the changes
suggested by the stakeholders
some of the changes are converting the
licenses to permanent licenses
striking the dates
moving some dates around from the
beginning of the year to mid-year so if
future legislature needs to make changes
so
any comments
please representative goalie thank you
mr chair uh looking at this amendment
i'm still trying to figure out where
this language came from because it
wasn't in the notes i have
in discussing changes what i had in
discussing the change was replacing
section one with the amendment that was
provided by oplc which i think we should
all have a copy of
um i don't see that in the bill
um
yeah let me go into the details of that
so the lawyer who is drafting it has
some difficulty
with the language proposed and he said
he needs to pull in some other language
and the conversion of the
h2
[Music]
it so the language from the amendment
from the oplc is
we live on page two where the conversion
so during initial subcommittee we had
testimonies
from um
see
nursing homes
so they were happy with the amendment
they came back they looked at it
um
youth camps
representatives
they were happy with it and
lindsay courtney also looked it over
she's
happy so i believe all the stakeholders
i i
still have an issue uh if you go to page
one
lines
22 to 24.
um
i i don't understand why
these individuals do not have to uh
continue uh to provide continuing
education when
licensees here in new hampshire have to
have continuing education
so we're setting a subclass of
individuals
that don't have to meet the requirements
that new hampshire licensees do
i think it should say they have to
maintain continuing education credits uh
20 yes thank you 22 through 24 to me
looks like it deals with emergency
licenses
which we are converting
so for the emergency license itself
whatever the emergency rules were
should remain in place but once they
convert to permanent then they'll be
under the
oplc's
control where they got to go through the
okay can i get a just a
reference to someone from oplc
thank you uh good morning joe shoemaker
director of licensing and board
administration for the office of
professional licensure
director courtney is is unavailable
today i know you she was here previously
um but i just had a couple questions on
this
um
the
emergency licenses
so i understand it was this would give
us the option anybody that was
previously
licensed
we would have the if they approached us
or we would have the option to issue
that emergency license again how long
would that emergency license
i i don't see that here
previously the emergency license you
know was only good while we had the
state of emergency and they expired at
that time
um
we've extended that now um and we have a
group of licenses that will expire in
may this year
so is the intent that
these individuals would be licensed
june june 30th 2023 the page three okay
okay thank you thank you the second
question i had was uh
section four
the senior nursing students
uh again this was very successful we had
senior nursing students that were
licensed during that emergency period
but they were only licensed i believed
and they had to take their nursing exam
so the language here appears to be you
know they could as long as they're
items
they would have a permanent license but
it doesn't
indicate anywhere
uh you know the requirement that they
would still have to pass their nursing
exams at that point
if they did not pass their nursing exam
i believe they did not become licensed
the
and then the last question i had was
section 8
states the
emergency licenses
shall be converted to a permanent
license
it states the emergency licenses shall
expire in june 30th 2023 again just
looking for clarification
between those two
sections
you
um
so the intent here is to convert them
and place them under the oplc's
jurisdiction
right
is that something new plc is comfortable
with
the order
i guess again just
we would be comfortable and did support
converting emergency license to
permanent license if they had been
previously
uh
but again it looks like the last section
is
emergency temporary licenses would
expire in june 2023 aren't those two
different things
they're either going to expire in june
2023 or they're automatically converted
if there is a conflict in the language
if
if that's the question
um
mr chairman yes please
i i sort of understood it that this is
just extending the emergency and that
the conversion is you then get an actual
so it's a little bit of apples and
oranges to say well you don't
regular rule things in this emergency
extension it's not really
um
what we're talking about is that applied
to all the emergency
licenses that were
issued for
health care it appears to me section 8
emergency licenses issued during the
coba 19 pandemic
on or before january 31st 2022
shall not be deemed to have lapsed upon
the state of emergency expiration and
shall be converted to a permanent
license
so again the hundreds of licenses that
were
temporary emergency this would
automatically we would have to we would
go back in the system get that list and
they would all be converted to
a
permanent license automatically is my
understanding and again now you go down
to 31
one
and it appears to say you know those
same emergency
temporary health healthcare licenses
remain
temporary
and they expire in june 30th 2023.
all right don't those it's it's one or
the other
isn't it wouldn't it well
i believe this gives time to the oplc to
convert them and the time is next
again i'm just giving you a
clarification if that if that's the
intent um right
right i believe that's the intent here
yeah
so it gives a year
and and again to do so it appears by the
language they shall be converted they
don't have to work again it would be on
oplc
to
do the research convert them and whether
they wouldn't have to request
that they'd liked a permanent license
we're just going to go back to that list
you had an emergency license you're now
going to get a permanent license in the
mail
or you know right we'll contact them
okay
clarifying that that's the intent yeah
they could have requested it before now
but they didn't
so we were
in this
problem that does make sense if the
intent is again to give us time
up through another year to convert them
that that makes sense
i guess the only open issue would be the
nursing students i just want to be clear
if they become licensed
during their senior year which again the
intent of that and it worked very well
to get them you know working under a
you know a license
you know while they're finishing school
i i think there needs to be some
notation or provision that they still
need to pass their
nclex exam
you know and if they don't their license
would be
revoked until they passed it you know
you can take it multiple times but i
believe that's how the
that temporary license worked during the
state of emergency which which did work
well
okay can we get a confirmation that they
must pass an exam today
or what what it is we're asking them to
do
like
do yeah please
wouldn't these senior nursing students
of a year ago already have passed or
i believe so so uh representative you're
to answer your question uh this
provision for senior nursing students
actually ended an act
sing it again
so i believe you're right the ones that
already were in this program would have
already taken their exam passed be
licensed so this is opening that that
door again so someone who was a junior
student
could not have
had an emergency license to be now
extended only the senior students who
would have either passed or failed
already
is it
so is this really a problem
the way i i read this again this would
be new students that are within five
months of their
uh the date of
application or graduation already have
an emergency
license
i guess i didn't understand that here
so the intent of this and again i'm
asking the intent of this
is
those that previously had that
who were seniors
got an emergency license have presumably
already passed or failed correct and you
can't probably create new senior nursing
students that have an emergency license
because the emergency has expired
so are we talking about some kind of
my my understanding of this was just
again by me reading this is that this
provision would be opened a second time
for for senior nursing students who have
an emergency order i i didn't i didn't
believe that that that was the
requirement
so clarification would be useful
yes
again i'm not sure
um you know what the the intent was
there
right
i gotta look at the original
um
line six says five months from the date
of application
what is the date
and when is the application submitted
would you know
you know prior to their their graduation
date again midway through that their
senior year or final year of their their
nursing program
that's that's always been in place they
is it because this this is all falling
under this 310 a1i emergency license
process so that
any of this only applies
or new light new
new applications would only apply again
under an emergency
situation so seniors this year
could not apply for that because we're
not in an emergency situation is that
what representative bailey is
indicating
okay
okay again just looking for clairvoyance
yeah i don't know either that's the
intent question
high school students that fought with
davey crockett are entitled to a texas
pension except there are no such thing
i
i i would yes i would thank you
because we were within the same chapter
so representatives would would that
clarify it for the oplc that we're
talking about the students who have
gone through the emergency license
um that is the intent that that would
make sense
i don't know if we need a change in the
amendment
that's stated but i guess it's for the
um full committee to discuss if we
we um
we have it under section 310
which is the emergency license processes
anyway
so
i'll representative golly please
thank you mr chair i
still would like to follow up from
oplc as to
whether or not these individuals that
are giving licenses
are just handed the license or they
taking the exam like every other
licensed nurse here in the state of new
hampshire had to take before they got
their license
we're talking about section 4 against
the nursing students senior nursing
it's just saying they are giving a
license they don't have to do continuing
ed like
every other licensed individual has to
do
they have given been given a lot of
[Music]
did the emergency licenses that were
issued did did they have expired dates
on them
so the emergency licenses that were
issued
besides the nursing students
have been extended by law through may
next next the end of this next month
but the way the the nursing student uh
senior nursing students to get them
working that was specifically tied to
the state of emergency
um
and we are not issuing those at this
time those did expire i believe in
january of this year
so again the way this is written if you
look at the first paragraph it doesn't
to me it didn't the amendment didn't
take into consideration a new state of
emergency
the opening paragraph paragraph says the
office of professional licensure and
certification
um
may issue emergency license to the
following applicants i don't think this
and again i think this is is the intent
of this was to
you know get people working in the
healthcare professions and and eliminate
barriers to workforce and
you know authorized us to expedite that
process to get health care workers
working even going forward on a
temporary basis say you know somebody's
moving here from out of state
um they have an active license in
another state and until they
you know
you know can
fulfill all the requirements for a
regular license they could work for up
to you know a temporary period i i
believe that was the intent here and we
certainly support that
okay
representative fellows i
it may be that i don't understand
everything that's going on but if we
didn't touch
existing statute
would the only
um
issue that was raised that we might want
to deal with
be that last paragraph on page two that
has to do
um it it it says it includes more but
but
should we just try to deal with like the
camp nurses and just write one paragraph
related to that
it's just a thought i don't know the
answer
nurses
are happy with the amendment so they
will be taken care of
other professions or especially part of
the problem is like what we've got here
has conflicts has conflicts within it
so i was trying to
i think at this point the question is do
senior nursing students do they go
and do they pass the test
that's really the only sticking point
everything else all the regular licenses
do have continuing education
requirements and their policies
dealing with that
so once they convert it they are under
the purview of the office right
so i don't think there's a problem with
that
some of the licenses were converted most
already
uh they were not converted
already but again they the temporary
emergency license have been extended
through may
of this year next third year first yep
yeah um so unless we do
something
you know here or otherwise those will
end
may 30th
so this again uh you know extends those
and it says again we will convert
all of those emergency licenses to
permanent licenses automatically
it would give us my understanding based
on the questions earlier it would give
us the one year until june 30th 2023 we
would have the year to convert those
licenses to a permanent status but it
would again would be automatic
as soon as we process them
representative goalie
thank you mr chair now i think i
understand where we are
the original bill
specifically dealt with extending
and correct me if i'm misreading this
those letters that were
issued under the emergency to
continue through 2024 originally and
with the getting their licenses which
wasn't any part of this bill that's
before us so this section is
reinstating the emergency which
i don't think we need to do that's all
we're looking to do is extend the
licenses that were issued under the
emergency order from what we were
talking about because they extended may
31st so i don't know why we have this
language in front of us reinstituting
thank you
i'm not sure we're doing that but we are
converting them
to permanent licenses
i see it as opening that whole program
back up and anyone who's a senior
nursing student can once again apply for
an emergency license by putting this
back in when we're looking just to
representative bailey if you're on the
microphone
yeah
that was my understanding that you'd
have to already have an emergency
not emergency license there's no
emergency
correct
i don't i'm not sure we have that power
i i didn't write this i'm sorry
representative
representative yeah
thank you
anybody else from
[Music]
the public wants to speak
or
is it like a computer thing that there
should be some ands and oars in there
you know always you have an emergency
license and you're a graduated senior
you know
and
absolutely it needs to stay for people
who who as of such and such a date
have
are operating with an emergency license
and then say except for the student
nurses
they get extended perhaps this gentleman
has shown a hole in this island would
you yeah
would it i'm sorry again just to clarify
at this time there are no emergency
student nursing licenses active
those expired in january of this year
so we don't want to create new ones
again i don't i don't know the intent or
you know who submitted this but if the
intent is to open that door again i do
think some additions should be added
or if the intent was
just copy in previous language and if
there was a misunderstanding that there
was some student nurses
currently
with an emergency license i i'm not sure
what would you strike out to make it
right
to me the simplest thing would be to
take that section out if if the
if the intent was
section
four
um
somebody thought there was currently
so again this is a this is an empty set
there are no senior nursing students
under the reference they expired in
january of this year so anybody under
that provision
so and again there's been some
discussion i i and i i would say
we we are open to
continuing that for
senior nursing students in that final
year but i i if that's the intent
you know i think that needs to be
clarified in there um
you know with the provision that you
know oplc may you know
may issue these licenses if people apply
um
and meet these
you know
and uh and again note that they they
need to pass that nursing exam because
at that point they would only be
eligible for this until they took out
one thought is that by the time this
bill gets passed
that um college for this year will be
over so when it says senior students we
will be this will be applying to the
students that are juniors right now
because the seniors right now they're
going to be
out
so
representative bailey our microphone
it was actually sort of issued to the
students of last year
right
there's already none of these people
that are seniors under the emergency
order that was last year you know
and again it was directly tied to the
previously
so the
there has been there was some confusion
there was there was questions there's
some thought that this continued on but
the temporary licenses of the emergency
licenses the key provision in there was
people had to have a license from
another state
that was verified when we gave them that
senior nursing students didn't have that
so when these were converted you know or
pushed out
you know and allowed to continue they
weren't included in that because they
didn't have an active license so again
that ended in january of this year a few
months ago thank you
just mechanically would you have to just
individually we have to re revisit this
with a version in which that paragraph
is struck out
um uh mr clark do you want to if you
save you for a few words
maybe maybe the microphone no no yeah
for the public online
thank you mr chairman
and i forget about that too yeah
robert clegg i'm with legislative
solutions
um i i'm not sure that you need to do
much of anything because if you look at
line 32 or 31 and 32
the licenses they're talking about is
anything that was issued on or before
january thirty one twenty twenty two
so
um
i i think you've covered it that
if there's anybody that's was a senior
nursing student
and was given an emergency who hasn't
taken that test yet would still have to
take it but
i don't i don't think that there's as
much confusion as we like it's a long
bill
but when i start at the very beginning
it says notwithstanding any of the law
the the the um office of professional
license and certification may issue
emergency license to the following
it doesn't say they shall it says they
may so if office of
licensing finds that there's a situation
in the best interest of the state of new
hampshire they don't have to but i think
that line 32 on page two sort of says it
all if you didn't have it before january
1 of 2022
i'm sorry january 31st
you're not included in this legislation
thank you i think that clarifies it
because that's exactly the date
that um
the pc representative was referring to
and that's by when the student nurse
so
yeah i think i'm happy with that
explanation
because the window is very small
yeah
yes
should we vote on on the amendment
do we have time to vote on the amendment
to move forward as a subcommittee that's
all right
um
i think i'm satisfied with the
explanations and i would like to move
this amendment forward
if i get a second so i
oh so i move that we passed the
amendment oh well
i guess i need a second just a second oh
a second okay i'll second it
okay thank you
um as we've had the discussion can we
just vote on it and turn it over to the
yeah all right
go ahead please call the roll
um let's see if i can get the order
right representative sanchez
yes
uh
the clerk votes yes
that was a no yes
uh representative fellows no just
available
oh
doesn't do anything for the federal
funding stuff it just
good morning everyone sorry about the
confusion
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
which is
recognizing the second thursday in
october as children's environmental
health day
she's not okay
does she substitute no
uh scott
representative schmidt would you care to
good morning colleagues
for the record peter schmidt
representing
stafford 19 which is uh dover awards one
and two
i'm pleased to uh
introduce senate bill 224 recognizing
the second thursday in october as
and
thank you representative schmidt scott
he's on the um
amendment you're on the amendment
he's on the amendment oh sorry my
mistake
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on senate bill 224 as
introduced
no
all right then we have
in that case i'd like to go into
executive session representative bailey
yes i'd like to move that it ought to
pass
[Music]
we should speak to your second
uh so the bond was never called in the
history of this statute of corner
testimony so it looks like it's not
needed so we should just go ahead with
okay is there any represent any further
discussion
yeah
i'd like to say that it
since it's been there for so long the
amount has become
fairly trivial
and so it's not really providing much
protection
and since it's never been needed
you know let's just to get rid of it
the value thank you
any other comments questions discussion
okay
uh in that case the motion is ought to
pass on senate bill 225 and the clerk
representative lekkis
yes
representative
plett
yes
yes representative mirner
representative pearson
yes
representative folsom yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative center nostalgia yes
representative goalie yes representative
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative funkner yes
the clerk votes yes representative
gormallo
yes
okay
19 to zero all right does anyone object
to consent
all right we open the public hearing on
the non-germain amendment in one minute
we have a right clock confirmation
to the right clock
they're
built really yeah it's immediate
i believe it's um it's a standard rule
in the building that if you have two
clocks in a room they're not allowed to
representative platt you'll fit in with
uh
it being 10 45 i'm opening the hearing
and i recognize representative pearson
thank you madam chair thank you members
of edna
i am on behalf of representative rhodes
bringing forward amendment 1506 h which
is an amendment to
senate bill 224
which replaces
the whole thing
the amendment is relative
to non-resident electrician license
reciprocity
and it will amend the
senate bill
with the language that's presented
one of the things that is unique
in the electrical world
is the fact that the national electric
code
which the nfpa
publishes
is
pretty much uniformly used so
this is not a case where
you have a
our neighbors are not
functioning under
a condition that is foreign to new
the other thing is the
if you look at the 8 000 hours of the
apprentice program that is also
something that is familiar in the in the
region so
that's the gist of this it's it's
relatively simple and
thank you representative pierce harrison
are there any
questions from the committee
representative fellows
you explain the difference between the
language that's in there now and where
this
not really
i can't i didn't write it um as far as
can you be more specific representative
well i don't have an electrician's
license me neither so
i don't know exactly
what we require now
but well it's in the it's in the the
amendment strikes out
the current well
true which is my issue
like i don't understand what was wrong
with the current language that says the
other states licensing
must be substantially equivalent or
higher to
ours well the only thing i can say and
as we've seen throughout the volumes and
volumes of laws that exist in the state
of new hampshire substantially
is up for interpretation i think this
language here is very definitive
and it would take away an interpretable
idea i believe one of the next
testifiers will explain some of the
difficulties
but yes representative platt
yes i'm no electrician but i'm a power
engineer
could one of the
inconsistencies between states is uh
have to do with what version of the
national electrical code has been
adopted by the state the massachusetts
might be one code ahead of us for
instance you are as a guy who at one
time worked for the nfpa i can tell you
that that that is um that is true with a
lot of standards in this particular case
there are folks behind me that
this guts the original intent of the
senate bill uh does it not with uh
children's environmental health day so
that no longer exists correct completely
and totally rewrites it and how does the
center feel about that
the feelings of the senate are
yes we don't worry about intentions
representative platt we have enough
any other questions
all right thank you very much
representative pearson
madam chair
members of the committee
my name is uh will infantine
in addition to
being one of your fellow representatives
i am the public member of the
electrician's board
i am not an electrician uh there are
other electricians behind me that will
be speaking
um
we are the electricians board is
for a number of reasons right now we
have 21 states that are involved with
reciprocation which allows
other electricians to come into new
hampshire
get their licenses and such
um
but some states just don't want to play
nice in the sandbox i was involved
recently with a case
uh where they contacted me an
individual had been a master electrician
for 20 years in the state of new jersey
he was more than qualified
he's moving his family to new hampshire
and we wanted him
unfortunately the rules of new jersey
are such that we could not accept
his
either a number of years or schooling or
whatever because of
because the new because of things that
new jersey wouldn't do so unfortunately
we walked him through the process and he
had to take some of the testing which
are required in new hampshire which he
passed very quickly and came
so we don't like the fact that these
things go on
but all the states don't want to
get involved with this reciprocation
and
this
amendment while it was just stated by
representative pearson uh
you know hey make it easier it's more
specific
well there's the other side of the coin
of that we have cases where people come
in front of the board and ask
that they be able to
obtain their license in new hampshire
when they haven't
met this criteria that we we currently
have the 8 000 hours which is the
criteria for an electrician in new
hampshire because they were maybe in the
military
someone who was an electrician at
seabrook
nuclear power plant
okay they hadn't been a licensed
electrician but we as a board could make
a decision that they had more than
enough qualifications to be able to
obtain their license and the board
approved that
so it does give us the flexibility
that we have now and this would take
obviously it's well intended and i can
understand the logic of someone wanting
to put that through
but it doesn't always work out that way
so it would hinder us in some
some situations
this comes up in connecticut and i'm
going to let an electrician speak to
this also the questions about
um
you know what other the criteria now
again i'm not an electrician
so i'd like them to speak on some of the
questions that were asked
previously
now
my last comment is going to be we would
love to take all
obviously new hampshire is a great place
to work and we could use as many
electricians as want to come to our
great state
so we'd be happy to work on that but we
don't think this is the right way
so thank you madam chairman thank you
how many states did you say are in that
compact
or agreement 21 21 thank you there's 19
and then there's another different pact
that we have with vermont and
massachusetts
okay for a total of 21. we have some
questions for you representative marsh
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
uh when i look at
rsa319c7 the licensing requirements it
looks like new hampshire applicants are
required to have 8 000 hours as an
apprentice and to pass an examination
and this would allow somebody coming
from another state to get a license with
8 000 hours and an active license are
there any states where one does not have
to pass an examination to get that
you know there probably are
but i'm i'm
i think i have the answer but i don't
i'm not 100 sure and i know an
individual standing behind me sitting
behind me will have that answer so i
respectfully just
thank you i'm glad to listen to the next
person
all right any other questions
representative lackas
thank you um
my question is is there
anyone um
well you gave one example but is there
actually is there anyone who you under
the current law you would not be able to
license if you wanted to
but you would be able to if this
probably someone that had the 8 000
hours and failed the test
well i said if they if they wanted to
i think it would be both ways it has to
be equal to or or equivalent or higher
now there may be a situation where the
board would look at someone who had more
hours than requiring maybe in some other
these other 21 states the criteria to
get an electrician's license is higher
so we would accept that
again there was another situation where
we had a former police officer who had
had an electrician's license but he had
not been involved in the trade nor had
he had a license for more than 10 years
so our rules say no you really can't you
have to go back and take some schooling
but because of who this gentleman was
and just amazing resume we allowed him
to take i think 2000 hours or something
uh take the upgraded courses and and do
something which the board is allowed to
make those decisions
um
where this wouldn't allow us to do that
you can't
sorry
i'm not on it
well i only introduced it for the
committee
all right go ahead representative pierce
i said person ask this question my
question is i just is this going to is
this
the rhodes amendment here is this going
to
um
the 21 states that have reciprocation is
currently is this going to
cause a problem with that or jeopardize
the current arrangement that the states
currently have
it very well could because once you put
this 8 000 hours in play and if that
gets changed across the country with
those states whether it goes up to 9 000
or or or to 7 000 or whatever and then
situation where we're no longer
equal or better
it could
not now but you know five ten years from
now we're sitting around and people
forgot about if this passes and all of a
sudden we're no longer
able to
deal with that reciprocation another
thing massachusetts is very strange and
again i'd love let someone behind me
speak about it we don't know how this is
going to affect the state where we have
probably the the biggest reciprocation
thank you other questions
all right thank you very much thank you
uh good morning madam chairman and uh
members
um i am the electrician that if you have
questions i can hopefully answer some
questions
um i'm currently uh working in
connecticut i live in winchester i have
a two-hour commute
i've been a electrician for 40 years
i got my journeyman license in 1986
and i had to have the schooling and in
connecticut you're required to have
eight thousand hours
i also took it a step further i actually
have twelve thousand hours and i have a
uh unlimited contractor's license
the
um
lately you know everybody's having a
hard time trying to get workers
and we have qualified licensed uh
people
that live here in the state
that may be licensed somewhere else
holding active licenses that i think
that would certainly help the labor
labor force
um i would certainly like to work in new
hampshire
you know unfortunately um it's not super
easy to get a license
you know the reciprocal agreements that
they do have in 21 states
the comment was made
excuse me about playing well in the
sandbox and basically i think
that comes down to well connecticut
won't reciprocate and take a new
hampshire license because connecticut
doesn't reciprocate with anybody because
you know that's the way it is down here
so because connecticut won't reciprocate
with new hampshire we're not going to
take connecticut licenses in my opinion
i think
it's low-hanging fruit this is a great
opportunity to get somebody like myself
with 40 years in the trade
never had i got a number unblemished
record
been very active in my trade and be able
to come in and do my work and practice
my craft right here in the great state
thank you have you applied to the board
for a license
i know i have not
okay thank you
okay thank you very much for your
testimony
good morning committee members i'm adam
chairman my name is stephen rancourt i'm
a licensed electrician in the state of
new hampshire
since 1986 i believe as well and i've
been uh i'm here representing the
electrical contractors business
association as well
on behalf of this bill
first like to say that we oppose this
bill as written while we understand the
intentions and we'll be more than
willing to work towards a
some sort of solution with the committee
if need be um
we could do that but there's a lot of
things
that are wrong this bill and i respect
uh the previous testimony from scott and
um
he seems from what he mentioned for
qualifications he's qualified i've been
going to the electricians board meeting
for almost 20 years now
and the board
is very
um
flexible
with people in their in their experience
and what it has a value for and how it
can translate to being able to get a
reciprocal so i would i would say that
that would be should have been the first
step before trying to change the laws of
our state is maybe applied to the board
and see if they denied him first before
we change our law so i think with his
experience he'd find he'd have a very
favorable outcome but i can't speak for
the board but i have been there many
meetings and they take experience
especially with military and other
experience and they count that towards
that accreditation the way this is
written right now
it says 8 000 hours in the
approved program
the approved program connecticut
massachusetts maine vermont new
hampshire could be all different
but also 8 000 hours is usually speaking
about ojt or practical field experience
and then there's additional hours of
schooling right now in the state of new
hampshire there's 600 hours of schooling
that's required
and it defines in
our rules in section 304.01
and
it defines just exactly what is required
to be equivalent or better
i think it's best that that stays in the
rules giving the board some flexibility
as representative infantile mentioned if
you change that
now whatever you were to put in this
bill is the only thing they can do
if they don't meet it
they're not going to get it whereas the
board now can give the has the
flexibility so i think it's important
that one
if it was written in here it should be
written at least the same as our rules
to put it in there and that it should be
thought about because again it takes
away uh any flexibility for anything
military people anybody somebody like
scott coming in and giving to him any
anybody who approaches the state for
boarding and if they're rejected they
have the ability to appeal and ask
especially if they've been licensed
to to take to try to take a test and
test out
and and if they can test and get that
they can um they can get their license
right there
testing is tough i'll admit i've been in
the business for a long time and if i
had to try and take the test again from
that many years ago i don't know how i
would do as well you know you forget
more than you remember over the years
but our experience
in working in it
and is worth the value and the board
takes that into account
um
the uh
if you've been
you come and you're looking for
reciprocal it doesn't state are you
reciprocating a master or journeyman
there are different requirements in
different states for that using
massachusetts for example in
massachusetts as a master i can't pull
permits i have to have a journeyman's
license but in new hampshire it's
reverse you can't pull a permit as a
journey as a masses so
just accepting somebody in based on this
guideline is not very good
there's people that have been
grandfathered over the years and never
did any schooling but when licensing
came out they they were given the
license and approved
a lot of change in technology has
changed over 30 40 years and
we're just trying to make sure that the
people we put in the state are safe for
the the constituents and and protect
them as well and not just somebody that
got it by chance and wants to just
reciprocate
um the
as we'll mention
we there's 19 states i believe in nero
which is a national electrical
reciprocal association that new
hampshire was instrumental in being a
part of in in building to try to create
additional reciprocals and there's two
other states that aren't part of near as
was mentioned massachusetts in vermont
but in maine vermont and hampshire
reciprocate we're the only state that
massachusetts reciprocates with right
now and i can tell you after spending a
year and a half to two years going to
meetings on that board as a invited to
their their committee to fix their
adjust their rules
that
if we do not have that wording in there
we will lose that reciprocation with
massachusetts they've removed it from
every other state we're the only one
left for somebody who's on the border
and i live in pelham new hampshire
that's going to have a huge effect on my
my livelihood so i would hope the board
considers all this um
we spoke spoke about the nec's national
and i understand that but we've also had
between all the other bills out here
senate bill 1681 everything else and
443 and all the local amendments that
get changed and everything it's
important for them to know what's going
on in the state before we just hand them
a license
in our testing
you have to know about rsa319c and the
rules 100. there's some questions on it
about that if you take the test so just
to make sure before you start in our
state there are different rules than
there are in connecticut or rhode island
or massachusetts
so just to say we just hand them to them
because they've been eight thousand
hours in an approved program that's not
really defined well in this wording i
don't think it's the best
is the best uh approach
um
there are some states that refuse to
reciprocate with us as well we've tried
to reach out to him many times and do
that and
but if you look and i did some research
and connecticut has the exact same law
that you have to be equivalent to
or above
what their standard is and there in the
uh
connecticut i would say 20-33a
it states that
the uh has to be substantially similar
to or higher than those of this state
so he's coming from a state that has the
same laws that we have but we want to
change our laws
so i just think that we should one that
should be approached to the board first
and they should uh
scott would have a better chance
probably trying to get that taken care
of
through the board um
the um
therefore local
not every state is on the same code we
know that from some of the other bills
that have gone through so i do not know
what connected it's on um i do know what
new hampshire's on working towards
getting in the next few months here so
there's a lot of variables and i think
that those need to be taken into account
i'll be glad to answer any questions
thank you representative schmidt has a
question
thank you madam chair
so you mentioned and we all know uh that
you're on the ecba
um and do know whether they are taking a
position or
whether it's
a general sentiment of your colleagues
that you've spoken with in opposition to
this amendment i've spoken to the
executive board and our governmental
affairs committee not the whole
membership yet but we're not in favor of
it as it's written because of the
rules that are already in place that we
any other questions representative
fontenot
thank you madam chair um and thank you
for taking my question
i'll clarify i too i'm a master
electrician in new hampshire and i've
had my license for about 30 years but um
in regards to this bill
i usually like to hope that when a bill
comes forward it's to
correct a problem
and so my question is is there a problem
that we need to correct with this bill
do you know how many
applicants are denied
licenses in new hampshire
yearly or
i do not know the number i know that
it's very few
i know that this isn't really fixing a
problem again and you know with all due
respect if you haven't gone to the board
and been denied then
they may have given him his license i
don't know that
um
we are one of the most i believe
um forefront
uh professions with reciprocal compared
to all the other people even in oplc and
stuff and everything and we've always
been open to it we started the nearest
so i mean
we're not against people coming to
licensing but we obviously want to
protect the state and constituents and
make sure that that person knows they're
doing it and it appears that scott does
have the qualifications but you still
have to go through the process right i
mean
you can't just walk in and say i want a
license you don't walk in and say i want
to take my driver's license and give it
to the new hampshire dmv and they give
you another one this paperwork to fill
out and the stuff you have to go through
and
i think we should try that following
representative
thank you
madam chairman thank you for taking my
question uh following on with
representative fontenot's question
um is this amendment fixable in in
language or would you just soon see the
amendment die because you're doing the
same thing by rule with more flexibility
i would prefer to see it
i tl with that because the flexibility
is in the rules if we put in the law as
you know that's it they have to have
whatever hours or or ojt or schooling we
require it's going to be clearly defined
and the board has no flexibility so
in a case like myself and possibly like
scott when i went and got my license
there was only two years of schooling
300 hours
i technically wouldn't qualify to go to
connecticut and get their license
because they require 600 hours i've been
an electrician for 30-something years
i'm in the same position
it's part of this evolution and change
in technology i mean you gotta
have a process in some way to protect
so
thank you the other questions
represent bailly i perhaps missed
probably a person who testified who at
assets are being brought forward
do we have any other questions
seeing none thank you sir
i'd call you dean the greek but uh
thank you mr chair mr chairman and
before i begin
on
the um
non-german amendment i'd like to thank
this committee
in regards to house bill 1681 and
adoption of the codes because it's very
important that the codes move forward
and i know this committee has put a lot
of work into it and it's nice to see
that the codes are moving forward so
again i really would like to thank the
committee
a little bit on my background i've been
a licensed electrician in new hampshire
since 1976
and i was in business for 25 years and
in 2001 i went to work for the state of
new hampshire as a state electrical
inspector and i covered the southern
area and then in 2011
i was the chief electrical inspector
until my retirement in um
january 1st of 2020
and as the chief electrical inspector
i worked with the board on many
occasions
and
i got to say our board as was mentioned
by earlier people in testimony that the
board is very open
the board
has no intent on making
new hampshire
closed for licensed electricians
i've seen many cases
where the current statute the way it's
written gives the board discretion
in the rules it does talk about the 600
hours of continuing ed
continuing education by an approved
provider
the 8 000 hours is considered ojt
it's not
as mentioned here it's not an
apprenticeship program it's 8 000 hours
of working in the field
the only people that have a specific
apprentice program
and it's actually more than eight
thousand i believe it's ten thousand is
the union
they have an apprenticeship program it's
a five-year program it's an excellent
program
but
the general eight thousand hours is what
we call ojt on the job training
so it's not a specific program
in my opinion once you tie
this
statue
to the 8 000 hours and even if you added
in the 600 hours of schooling
you've now tied the board's hand
i've seen cases
where the board has approved people
either to get a license or to sit and
take the exam
as the chief electrical inspector for
nine years
i had been contacted over time by many
people seeking to get a license in new
hampshire wanting to move here or work
here for whatever the reason might be
and my advice to them was you go to the
board
you give them all the documentation the
board is very open
if you go to the board and you just say
well i did this i did this
obviously they're not going to
you know accept what you're trying to do
but if you go there with documentation
okay here's what i had for education
here's my working hours
they've been very open
and
i can actually say i don't recall them
ever refusing anyone that had
qualifications either equal to
or above
what we require
it's when somebody goes before the board
and they don't provide the backup of the
documentation the board will say well
you need to do this then once you you
know complete this portion come back to
us
and we'll reconsider
and i've served in the um well actually
19 years working for the state
i've seen the board
do this a number of times with many
people where they they're always willing
to help them
get their license
so
that's the one of the important things
that the board has done and i can also
tell you
at the request of the board as the chief
inspector
i submitted a letter to the state of
connecticut requesting consideration for
reciprocation
never got a response
i also submitted to the state of rhode
island never got a response
so
obviously there are states that out that
are out there that don't want to
reciprocate even if they have as was
mentioned earlier um
by mr rancourt
they have similar requirements in their
statute as we do but they don't want to
and if anybody has any questions
thank you very much are there any
questions representative schmidt
thank you madam chair uh so dean
some of us have heard your name but
nobody heard your name this morning so
could you say your name sotericopoulos
thank you thank you i forgot to and it's
any other questions
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
all right
not seeing none i'll close the hearing
on senate bill 224 and its non-germain
amendment and open the hearing on senate
represent a merchant you'll have to
introduce it because there's no senators
so i bring before the committee
senate bill 450.
senate bill 450 is based upon
discussions we've had during the last
year with the board and also during some
of the working sessions and feedback we
received
and fundamentally it's to help correct
some of the language in the bill to make
simplified if you will to make it
clarify
different parts of it
and if you would madam chair i can walk
the committee through the changes the
recommendations
but before i do that one of the things i
wanted to be clear on is the role of the
prescription drug affordability board
this seems to be some confusion the last
time i was here
i'd like to
clarify some of that
prescription drugs are an extremely
expensive proposition for the taxpayers
of this country the state
and as governmental entities
both at state level municipalities the
county
school districts
we need to be good stewards of taxpayers
dollars
and we have to be sure that we're
spending those dollars wisely
that's why we want to be sure that that
point in time is we don't have taxpayers
dollars being spent unwisely
so if you look at the whole thing about
pricing of prescription drugs it's not
very transparent matter of fact it's
very opaque
as i mentioned before
the berkeley group and the 2020 report
share that manufacturers which everyone
wants to point a finger to
as a scapegoat
received less than 50 percent
of the gross reimbursement
of what's paid in the marketplace
in 2013 that was 67
so if the prescription drugs and the
price of certain things the revenue
stream
going back to the manufacturers is now
less than 50 percent
where it was 67 percent
the question is where's the money going
so the task before the prescription drug
affordability board is fundamentally to
try to bring greater transparency
to the marketplace
for governmental entities to help ensure
that they're actually
paying the prices they should pay
but back to the bill itself on 450 and i
do have some testimonial
in respect to the chair person
i should probably back up
for the record my name is gary merchant
representative merchant for sullivan
county district 4
which is in
ward 2 claremont new hampshire
and also for the record i am the
chairman of the prescription drug
and madam chair do you want me to
distribute this at the end of my
talk
i already have
okay
so if we walk through what we're trying
to do with house senate bill 450
on behalf of senator sherman
there's a confusion if you look at page
one
lines four five and six
what came to our attention was that
there are entities that work with a
manufacturer that don't actually sell
the product but they're considered by
the fda to be quote a relabeler or
repackager
for example
when a company
makes the product they could make
something with 55 gallon drum of tablets
in it
so they subcontract it to somebody to
repackage that drug into smaller
containers that's a repackager
however sometimes every packager may
also sell the drug themselves
so there's confusion between the
language and the statute to who's
actually the manufacturer and what we
wanted to do at that point in time is
saying it's the entity that controls
assess the price
not somebody who acts as a subcontractor
to the actual manufacturer that sells
if you go back and look at the pricing
unit
which is on line eight
in a pharmacy if you get a bottle
of a thousand tablets
the smallest dispensable unit
so it's very difficult to standardize
across pricing
to sit there and say is it a tablet out
of a bottle of a thousand is a tablet of
a bottle of a hundred
i could have a jar of one pound of cream
and dispense an ounce out of it
so to order to make that more simplified
and be consistent this actually came
from the manufacturing community
is their recommendation was to go buy
the smallest available package unit
that you can purchase in a pharmacy
would it be a bottle of 30 100 1 000
whatever it's going to be whether it
comes in a tube with 30 grams it comes
in a pound jar but it's the smallest
available package in the marketplace
that a pharmacist can buy
that standardizes that down to a certain
point it clarifies
it we also had confusion if you go back
and look at line 16.
there's confusion thinking that you have
to be a legislator to be on the
committee on the board
and that is not the case at all
so all this does is really clearly state
that you do not have to be a legislator
to be on
the board in fact
a lot of people we want on the board who
have the expertise and the knowledge
and the clinical skills and so forth
probably don't reside in the house or
the senate so we want to ensure we have
as a broader
population to choose from to be on the
down through 30 you'll see we've changed
the alternates from one to two the
rationale to that is
we have a lot of legislators on the
board
of the eight six of us sit on the board
so currently is causing a problem
between the calendars on the legislative
side and the board side so we've had
times where it's been difficult for us
to get a physical quorum together so
we're trying to increase the number of
if you look on page two
again the same thing is you want to
ensure that the board has the authority
to hire staff
and we talked about the uniqueness of
the person we're looking for
is what i call a unicorn it's not
somebody out there that's easily
available in the marketplace
so to increase the opportunity for us to
find the talent that we need
we wanted to move it into a quote
unclassified position
to allow the people and the personnel
to make
the job great according to what the
marketplace demands
the executive director also to be sure
it's somebody that the board
has the authority to hire to review
their credentials
because it's really the board that's
driving
and we want to be sure the board's the
one ultimately just making that decision
about who are they going to hire if
you're the one hiring that person should
be the one responsible for the
expectations and setting those
expectations at the same time
if things aren't working out the way you
would they should
have the ability to alleviate the
problem
on line 17 on page two we ran into an
issue with some of the
pbms some pbms
do work on behalf of third parties
large insurance companies they don't per
se pay take the financial responsibility
but they pay the claims
so to eliminate the issue of confusion
between
am i in am i out we basically at that
point time standardized it and said if
you're paying claims as well as taking
financial responsibility you're in
you're considered a pbm
we also heard from the this committee
about the runner-in run away train
that the board could artificially
raise as much money as it wants
so to
approach that problem if you look at
line 23
and 24 like other boards we're capped at
125 percent
of what's there
to be sure that the board doesn't have
unfettered access to income beyond what
its needs are
if you look at line 27 through 28
again the entity and assessment fee they
can appeal it that was a question came
up before is there a way for them to
appeal the assessment fee that was
addressed in here as well
and line 31 just talks about the appeals
process we're working on the rules
to put that behind it so that's where
that's at
and the last one is also
the criminal penalty to be sure we talk
about protecting confidentiality because
a lot of this is very confidential
is that there's a criminal penalty if
you are
willingly providing data that's
confidential to a third party
then you're going to pay the price
there's a criminal penalty involved with
it which is on line eight
and if you look at lines
is creating a non-lapsing fund so the
board at that point in time will have
the ability to collect this the
assessment fees and disperse them as
well to control
or to fund the board's operations so
that's what senate bill
450 is all about
it's trying to take what we learned over
the last year
take the comments you folks made to this
committee to to myself and others
including senator sherman and try to
address some of the issues that you
raised during that hearing all day
questions
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
representing judy
good morning representative
i don't know if you
can answer me that question
um
why someone have to be legislator
to to become in the community
you don't have to be we're trying to
clarify and be clear that you don't have
we don't have to
senator jude yes because there's been
confusion
that
you had to be a legislator to be on the
committee it wasn't required but we
wanted to be clear in those statute that
that's not a
requirement okay
all right thank you
thank you madam chair
good morning gary uh so honey uh
tell me has the board taken a position
on the amendment you're offering today
no the board has not taken an amendment
yeah well
we did review it senator sherman did
review with the board but no we did not
take a a position on the on the bill per
se but he did address the board and we
supported what he wanted to include in
the amendment
in his bill but to ask a question did we
specifically vote on it that i do not
believe we did
but we're all behind it follow up
so not a formal vote but are you telling
me that essentially the board is in
favor of these changes
yes the board is in favor of the changes
thank you
other questions
i have one how does a minimum fee
correlate with not exceeding 25 125
percent of your expenses
basically
i'm not quite sure i follow you um miss
if you look at it on
line 16 page 2 it says annual
assessments of not less than 500
line 23
the aggregate level of assessment shall
be amount to meet the board's
expenditures provided such amount may
not exceed 125 of annual costs
that appears to be
contradictory or possibly an incentive
to inflate your costs because you have a
set amount coming in what do you do if
the more if that 500
produces
150 of your expenses
at that point in time my understanding
according to the statute we'd have to
find a way to reduce our expenses to
meet that obligation
what if it's it's a hund what if it
produces 150 of your expenses
what will you do will you refund the the
overages or will you increase your
expenses
i would say at that point in time our
budget is based upon what our needs are
and if the needs exceed the money coming
and exceeds the needs then at that point
in time there would be a refund going
back to them the challenge we have in
the statute
is
which has to go back in the rules is the
process to do that
the rules cannot contradict the statute
so i'd be interested in seeing it thank
you
does anyone else have a question
representative pearson
thank you madam chair thank you
representative merchant for for coming
here it kind of ties along
the question with the chair
why not have your your fee structure set
up to be
similar to what
goes on in the oplc in that the fees
based on the need and not
have
this
statement of an annual assessment of not
less than 500 why not just make it where
the the board will set the fee as
necessary
you know what
that's a good point i mean one of the
things we could do at that point in time
the committee is do an amendment to the
bill
and amend it that way accordingly i mean
i i we're not trying to turn the board
into a quote revenue producer for the
state
we're trying to be sure we're frugal
with the money both with taxpayer monies
as well as what comes in from anybody
else so if the committee's comfortable
with making an amendment to this bill
to do that
i think if that will make it past that
no they could
the board
can have rule making can't have
authority to set the fee in rules but
generally we like to give them some
guidance
and not less than 500 is not the kind of
guidance we would normally give
i'm open to um the committee i
understand the concern
it's a valid one obviously so there's a
way for the committee to work on an
amendment to um tackle that
because again be clear the board is a
frugal board we're just trying to be
sure we have the funds to make the board
operational thank you
representative schmidt
it has been brought to my attention
madam chair
that a an existing
uh section of the statute states
and that is in
126 bb colon 8
under funding
the last line of
section e reads the board may wave
assessments otherwise do under
sub-paragraphs
c
as in center and e is an excellent when
a waiver is determined to be in the best
interest of the board and the parties to
be assessed
so i think that addresses the questions
that we're currently discussing
thank you representative smith for your
research are there any other questions
seeing none thank you very much
and madam chair was a copy of my
testimony you got copies of your
testimony and passed them around thank
you very much thank you madam chair
while representative merchant was
testifying in response to one of the
questions senator sherman was uh
indicating so perhaps we could have he's
the next one up
but perhaps we could have him uh
answer that question immediately
thank you represent uh
senator sherman and i hope you will not
need to repeat what representative
merchant has so dutifully reported
no i won't thank you madam chair and for
the record my name is tom sherman once a
representative always a representative
but
currently senator
uh representing 11 towns on the seacoast
district 24
to answer the question that was raised i
would have no problem in line 16
i think it works if you just took out
the words of not less than 500 assessed
um
that leaves
the that gets rid of that i i
was trying to remember where that number
came from but i think it's arbitrary and
unnecessary and i appreciate the chairs
pointing that out
um
so the goal here is to follow oplc
as representative pearson pointed out
and the
125 percent is the language that's
in the board of medicine and the other
and just to be clear this is similar to
the bill
parts of this are similar to the bill
you heard earlier coming from the house
these bills were both fully supported by
the board
they have been
amended slightly in answer to the
concerns that were raised by the board
and the two most important there
by i'm sorry by this committee the two
most important there were putting limits
on fee raising ability that's the 125
and the other was
putting in
an appeals process
so that and that was a direct response
to questions raised so
the goal has been to be responsible
or responsive to
concerns raised by this committee and
also by some of the people on fiscal
process under
being undertaken there
to make it possible for us to accept
fees
there had been questions about the
intent of the board and
i don't want to reiterate the intent of
the board except to say
this is a very very very complex
process if you've ever been a patient
no
you know i'm a provider and a patient if
you've ever been a patient you know how
complex
pharmacy costs are whether it's a
hospital or your own office or you're a
patient and you're just going to the
person to the drug store
you can get five different quotes for
the same drug
and then there's generic and there's
brand name and so it gets very confusing
and the goal of this
board
is to try to clarify
for the state
what the costs are and how to optimize
those costs and there had been some
misinterpretation of the goal of the
board we're not setting prices there's
no
fees i'm sorry there's no
uh fixing of prices there's no penalties
there's
built into this
it's really just trying to optimize the
state expense and the transparency
around
why things cost what they cost
and that
is a way of enhancing transparency we've
talked about this in other areas like
hospital charges and doctors charges and
how confusing it is for patients
but remember we have eight thousand
state employees we have ten thousand so
we still have two thousand job openings
but that's a lot of people that's a lot
of cost
um including
legislators who are on the health plan
so this is to make us smarter to clarify
the system make it more transparent and
in the end the smarter we get
the more we understand where there can
be savings without any
decrease in quality of the health care
provided
it will save the state money and that's
the whole goal so
i hope that's clear but i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you senator are there any
questions
seeing none thank you
representative fellows excuse me yeah i
just had a question had have there been
bills this year that
right there was one and this is the we
one was in the senate with um and the
senators on
the committee are senator carson and me
uh so and
senator rosenwald is an alternate
and so
this was the one that came from the
senate senator carson and i
worked on this together
and then the house bill you have an
any other questions representative
schmidt
thank you madam chair so senator sherman
uh i think the
the nagging question that we all have
given the complexity that you've alluded
to uh several times in your testimony
today but also previously is
that this is a very complicated complex
situation um and uh
i got the impression but i'd like to
have you go on the record whether the
this this board actually does work and
is functioning in the fashion in which
it was intended other than the fiscal
aspects that that we're trying to
wrestle with today
um
the short answer is yes we're
probably moving forward
under representative merchant's guidance
with
we're probably the most advanced now in
the country of these types of boards
we are very excited about
the level of understanding the board
actually has now we've had multiple
training sessions so that we are
getting as clear as we possibly can on
this very very difficult to understand
process
um
but
that being said you know we we have to
have these things in place to really be
able to function the way it was intended
and that's why we've come to the
really sort of housekeeping measures so
that we can actually
complete our making and
start doing the business of the board in
a robust way but
the the trajectory is very positive the
the uh
the
com the board has
done a lot of work we've met many many
hours and
really are on a on a great glide path
towards being able to
serve the state by making
us as
smart as possible about how we
deal with this very expensive part of
so i noticed the effective date is july
1st 2022
is there a specific reason why it should
not be upon passage
uh because it sounds to me like some of
these aspects are pretty time sensitive
um
it would be
great if it were on passage
we'll take what we can get in terms of
being able to get started you know july
2022 is is not very far in the distance
so
we're meeting this afternoon we meet
regularly and we'll continue to do so
until we get
really until we get this
fully functional
it does seem to me that on upon passage
would be better
thank you
yeah i would agree that if you're going
to do an amendment to
fix line 16 on page two
changing the effective date on passage
would be welcome
thank you very much senator thank you
i have four cards from different members
of the aarp
if
all of you wanting five minutes which i
suspect would probably be fairly
repetitive would you pick whomever you
or you could testify together whichever
okay please turn your mic on and
thank you madam chairman
and i am karen omar dorsch i live in san
bernardin new hampshire
and
madam chairman and members of the
committee thank you for what you do
i came today to support senate bill 450
relating to the prescription board
affordability
excuse me the prescription drug
board i'm a volunteer for aarp
and a member of the capital city task
force
i would like to share a story with you
today that is margie's story margie is a
resident of new hampshire and she lives
with multiple sclerosis
it is a very painful and expensive
disorder
one of her medications
cost
ten thousand dollars every three months
maggie's insurance coverage does help
her afford this medication but she is
afraid that that won't always be the
case
because in the past the board has her
her
insurance has abruptly
denied her coverage of
a phys physician's recommended
medication
changes and gaps
in her coverage threatened her health
and her hard-won stability
without the medication
she is likely to relapse
and
probably lose what stability that she
has gained
and to think about this is absolutely
terrifying to margie
she does not want to lose more to than
she already has physically and
emotionally to
ms
so while the prescription board afford
excuse me prescription drug
affordability board
cannot set drug prices
it will help to bring accountability and
transparency by asking questions to the
pharmaceutical companies as to how there
is this widely varying
and seemingly
random prices that are set
i hope that you will support this
legislation that is so important to so
very many of our granite state residents
and thank you for listening to my
testimony
thank you very much will you take
i don't see any so thank you thank you
again
excuse me representative schmidt did you
have a question
i have a question uh the ladies uh
reading from prepared testimony can you
okay thank you
you give it to our clerk we'll include
it in that in the uh record of the of
you just shut your oh there you go
good morning
my name is mary roberge and i live in
manchester new hampshire and like karen
i am also a aarp volunteer and a member
of the capital city task force
i just wanted to
say that this board was created in a
bipartisan way in 2020
to monitor the changes of the cost of
prescription drugs and to have
transparency within the drug industry
doing this
keeps all new hampshire residents
informed of any price increases that may
affect their ability to afford the
medications they use
my story involves my mother
she like many new hampshire residents
felt the increases
in prescription drug prices
she lived on social security
it was not a lot of money
but one of her medications
was over half the cost of what her
social security benefit was
she needed this medication in order to
maintain the quality of life that she
deserved and she was alive and vibrant
lady
i just would like to say that the people
of new hampshire do deserve and they
need
fair drug prices
they shouldn't have to choose between
their life-saving medications
and food or any other necessity of their
life
it is important to nearly 85 percent of
the new hampshire residents over 45
who are from all political parties to
purchase affordable medications
and i like karen to
ask this board to
support this bill thank you very much
thank you
i take it you're roger does rosieus yes
good morning madam chairperson and
members of the committee for the record
uh my name is roger deroser
and i am a resident of concord new
hampshire
i am here today in support of senate
bill 450 related to the prescription
drug affordability board
i am a volunteer with the aarp
capital city task force
as an aarp capital city task force
member
i have been advocating for the passage
of this original legislation since 2020
and we were happy when governor sununu
signed the drug affordability board act
into law
i really hope this is a last hurdle it
is such an important piece of
legislation
i can tell you that the increasing price
of prescription drugs is of great
concern to folks across new hampshire
my fellow concord residents dan and
grace are both 62 years of age
and live right here just a few miles
from where we are meeting
dan is newly retired and grace worked a
part-time job until she was diagnosed
with colorectal cancer
while grace was undergoing chemotherapy
and receiving radiation treatments their
32 year old son michael
was diagnosed with leukemia
this posed even more challenges for a
michael a musician had accepted a job
teaching music when he was diagnosed and
was significantly underinsured
in addition to other medications
michael's chemotherapy drug
then christine
cost roughly fifteen thousand dollars
per month
unfortunately his insurance pays very
little of this exorbitant expense
to cover michael's prescription drugs
and other related costs
dan and grace were forced to take out a
second mortgage on their home
no one should have to do that to keep a
family member alive
i'm glad the prescription drug
affordability board is up and running
hopefully we can move forward finally to
allow the board to do its job in
gathering information and asking
questions
so we can have a better transparency on
how drug prices are set and
accountability from the drug companies
thank you for your attention
thank you very much other questions
yes good morning uh madam chairwoman my
name is jennifer delaney i'm the
associate state director for advocacy
for aarp new hampshire
thank you very much for the opportunity
to testify before you this morning in
support of sb 450. pardon me
is as a director of advocacy you're a
lobbyist correct yes i am
no badge
oh it's right here
sorry pardon me i should have had it up
higher my apologies
as you know aarp is the nation's largest
non-profit nonpartisan organization
dedicated to empowering people
over the age of 50. we have 38 million
members nationwide and more than 215 000
here in the granite state i won't take
up too much of your time uh you have
already been
very kind in allowing aarp to uh
volunteers to testify
i would just like to say add that
this is mostly a housekeeping bill
and that aarp supports this piece of
legislation
all of the parties that came to the
table
when this bill was in the senate were
heard and are in agreement on this piece
of legislation additionally it passed
the senate with a unanimous voice vote
and we request the committee vote in
favor of sb 450. thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you for your testimony other
questions
seeing none
okay good morning madam chair honorable
members of the committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
and new futures as many of you know new
futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
health policy and advocacy organization
we work to ensure access to quality
affordable health care across the state
uh i don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said this morning uh
certainly i can't uh i can't talk to the
need for uh to pass this bill any better
than
uh than our friends just uh have done
throughout the morning i do want to
emphasize our strong support for this
bill uh certainly the pdab is absolutely
critical tool for helping our state to
address the rising cost of uh
prescription drugs which really is just
a health care crisis in our state is
really impacting people's access to
access to care um so with that you have
my written testimony i will ask you to
vote this bill ought to pass i'm happy
to take questions
thank you very much are there questions
okay don't think
chair maguire members of the committee
my name is holly stevens i am the
director of public policy for nami new
hampshire and i also will try not to
take up too much of your time today
because i think you know you heard this
once
about the peta once already
a couple months ago
senate bill 450. there were two
bills two housekeeping bills one was
started in the house one was started in
the senate since there were members of
both the house and senate on the board
which is why they were started in both
bodies but they were different bills it
wasn't that the same bill was started in
each body
and after this committee
expressed some concerns and i know that
representative leishman also expressed
concerns i had a conversation with him
about those concerns um and so when
senate bill 450 was in
the senate
with
heidi kroll of ahip who is the person um
that i uh afterwards found out had some
of the concerns about the conflicts the
conflict of interest provisions on the
board had conversations with ms kroll
as well as senator bradley and senator
sherman
and really worked on senate bill 450 in
order to incorporate the concerns that
we heard
in this committee the concerns that miss
kroll brought up so that
um
you know these these concerns were
addressed and
um really again came together uh
bipartisanly
um
and really
listen to the stakeholders that
made themselves available in order to
address the concerns
so i hope that you will find that senate
bill 450 addresses some of the concerns
or all of the concerns that you had
earlier this session with the house bill
um
and again i just wanted to remind the
committee that two years ago this was
one of only
three bills that senator excuse me
governor sununu came and testified on
and
that he what he said at the time was
this bill will create a drug
affordability board in new hampshire to
monitor changes in the cost of
prescription drugs to keep the industry
honest
and to keep an eye on the prices and
prevent price spikes often many of the
challenges in health care can start to
be addressed through greater
transparency in pricing and again that's
transparency in pricing not fixing the
prices
transparency
brings scrutiny and accountability as to
why the cost of a particular drug is
high or higher than similar drugs and he
went on to say that he looked forward to
signing the bill
but in addition to the transparency you
heard today about
the the fact that this
bill allows the board to really be in in
innovative
when it comes to
any public payers inc including
municipal
and trying to get a handle on what the
municipalities are paying for drugs and
what the state is paying for drugs so
the one of the main functions of this
board is to save money for the state
and so i really encourage you to take a
look at this bill
if it doesn't address all your concerns
you know let uh
representative emergent merchant senator
sherman myself
mr barry um or miss delaney know and
we'd be more than happy to work with you
further on it but i do believe that
addressed all the concerns that we heard
about a couple months ago with that i
will take any questions
okay seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you is there anyone else
okay
seeing none i will close the public
hearing
uh
it's almost noon
i'd like to have the republicans here at
one o'clock for a caucus the committee
will resume
at
so
okay welcome back guys
i'm going to start with the bills that
have messy amendments that we might need
to change dir because of our discussions
so that we have time to get them rev
rewritten
and then we'll go on to the ones with
simpler amendments
okay
397 there's an amendment in work so we
won't do that
um i think senate bill 330
representative shuett
is the neck is the
yes madam chair i believe everyone has
a copy of the
latest iteration
amendment 1732 h
which is basically the same as
however
as it was called to my attention that
the
study in the first part of the bill
i had
a report date of november 1 of 2023
which would have overlapped
with the oversight committee
and that seemed like
a bit of a double effort
so i changed
uh if you look on page two
of the amendment lines 20-22
that now calls for the report
of the chaptered study
to have its final report done on
november 1 of 2022
therefore any recommendations that they
make
could be taken up by the oversight
committee which commences in january of
that's the only change from
okay
is there a second by the way and some is
there someone who wishes to speak to
i'll second okay do you wish to speak to
your second
uh no i think representative schuett
clarified
okay
and
representative schuett does your
amendment remove the boxing and
wrestling commission issues
yes it deletes the
reference to
boxing and wrestling just as
amendment 1520 did
and
this committee in a straw poll if
everyone remembers uh
decided that the boxing and wrestling
commission did not belong in oplc
as it doesn't actually license
individuals it just
okay
all right
okay not seeing any
the motion is to adopt amendment 1732 h
to senate bill 330.
representative lucas
yes representative mirner
yes
representative plett yes representative
pearson
yes representative folsom yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative santo nostazo yes
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative yeah
yes representative votes yes
representative gormallo yes
oh i'm so sorry i guess not the chair
yes
it's now it's now it's really 19 to zero
for what's worth i do the same thing on
my committee all the time
thank you
it's common
all right so that's we have adopted the
amendment is there any further
discussion on the bill representative
basically the motion is the amendment
um
i think we all agree that uh
oversight of some of the issues and
problems that we've seen
with oplc need to be addressed
and that was the major impetus for this
amendment was to create the
oversight committee
yes i'll agree we had a
large number of bills this year
regarding the relationship of the boards
to oplc
and
it's pretty obvious that it's not as
smooth and efficient
as it ought to be
and
i think that we it's worthy of some
anyone
all else seeing none the motion is ought
to pass as amended
uh madam chair did you wish to bring up
the
matter that we discussed oh yes
the other issue is that the ways and
means committee
is concerned that we're looking at the
funding in the study committee
and
they would like to be represented on it
so if that were to be
specify a third member or
make a bigger committee
and i'd
like to hear the committee which is
wants to to make such an amendment
representative pearson i just have a
question in reference to
uh you know ways and means
looks at you know how how we fund things
typically with these committees they're
funded through
when the oplc sets the fees they're
funded through the fees so
i don't i don't really know that ways
and means necessarily has to be involved
here unless they're unless they think
we're they're going to be coming up with
alternative funding methods other than
the current price the reason they think
they should be involved is that we took
the study committee on funding
out of senate bill 313 and folded it
into the study committee here
seeing as how the
i don't know about you but i had a
massive fear i'd be appointed both of
them
and and their the functions of the two
study committees were close enough that
it made sense to combine them
um
i would be delighted to have a member
for ways and means but i'm not sure it's
necessary because we're not going to be
changing the
the concept that the license fees bring
in enough
to cover their expenses but
i'm willing to bow to the rest of the
committee to say that we should consider
okay representative uh platinum and
bailey and then shewit
okay the way i read the amendment that
just passed is three members of the
house of representatives two of
whom are spoken for health and human
services and uh
human service and elderly affairs uh
excuse me executive edna and health and
human services and early affairs which
leaves a third member which could be
from ways and means
i would agree with that as well
representative bailey
oh okay thank you representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
yeah i think i think that probably
allows room for that person and
i'd be happy to
state
in the blurb that
the committee felt that
the third slot could go to a ways and
means member
i will say that the argument was put to
me from a member of ways and means also
that they had
originally instituted the fees
that existed in oplc but i
counter pointed that that was some time
ago that they did that they haven't
really been involved
in setting the fees for a number of
years that i'm aware of it's mostly been
through our committee and the senate
edna
okay
represent goalie
thank you madam chair and i too can go
along with the amendment bill as amended
um without the additional adding of
ways and means
we've
done a number of changes lately removing
fees and letting oplc set the fees in
stan statement with the 125 percent rule
um so i i feel comfortable with the way
it is right now okay thank you anyone
else
all right representing fellows
thank you madam chair i i just actually
would just like to ask people's opinion
that right now there's four members
of of the
committee and that's an even number and
do you
think
we need to make it a
not even number ace not for sunday
committee
they're they're only making
recommendations and a 3-1 or a 2-2
recommendation will still get a minority
report
on a regulatory committee i would agree
with you completely well in in that case
i don't see any reason to make any
changes
okay
anyone else over here
right
all right that case the motions ought to
pass with amendment on senate bill 330
and the clerk can call the roll
representative mirner yes representative
klett yes representative pearson
yes representative folsom yes
representative l.a girl yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative santo nostalo
yes representative goalie yes
representative shewett
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative faulkner yes
representative votes yes representative
gormallo yes
and the chair yes
19 to 0.
excellent is there any objection to
consent
all right seeing none we will put it on
and
for everybody that's making motions the
absolute deadline for this
is this week so i would very much
appreciate your
your committee reports as soon as
possible like today
yeah we want to go over the amendment
house bill senate bill 357
i hope so that is amendment 1625 correct
okay
take him out of chair
and i'll
go back to the original just so we can
make reference the
senate bill 357 is was done at the
request of the
ptsd commission
and
what the
it's not a total rewrite what this does
is the in the it reestablishes the
commission the commission
was expiring and
re-re-establishes that commission
so the new sections part two and beyond
fixes a couple of things
there was
um
there was a concern
about
dispatchers that was they were they were
added in
one of the things that the
chairman mcguire wanted to specify is
that no current
officers would be required to go to
their respective academies
there is a cost associated with that and
so that was added into
the amendment
on several locations where that would be
appropriate as an example line 10 at the
beginning
okay
um the other thing is it specifies
that the annual refresher
um
on this will be done online
in as we heard from testimony from the
various folks that's just something that
would be included in their normal
training schedules and something they
can do
where they're at and it doesn't require
them to travel
what it does also do this bill does is
it puts into statute that when
new hires are going through their
respective academies they do go through
the initial training on the
and finally the last thing it does is as
has happened way too many times in the
past the department of corrections has
seemed to be the stepchild of things
so
the
online 28 it just repeats the law
enforcement one but in reference to
corrections officers mirroring the
language that they need the training
initially through their academy and that
current officers are not required to go
back to their respective academy
for
any sort of refresher training
okay
thank you is there a second to this
second okay
who is that i'll go okay thank you
all right
do you wish to speak to your second
nope
okay
i'd like to to comment that when i first
saw the title of this bill i thought it
was about training
first responders to deal with
individuals who have mental health
issues but this is actually
to provide mental health training for
themselves which is
also valid and important
any other comments or questions
represents like us
i i support not requiring uh current
officers to have to go to the academy
for in person but
um under this what kind of uh initial
training would they get is there gonna
be something online they'll get or or
what
no when they're in their respective
academies it would just be a
module that they go through both
academies do this already
um
in a
in a kind of a
infant stage of the
of the training so
uh this would just
make this one it would statutorily
require it because right now it doesn't
and two
um this would allow both academies which
are currently developing
the training they're already doing it
just
just to make it codified that it's part
of the both academy's processes i wasn't
referring to the academy it's just uh
what if anything for current offices
okay that's all being developed by both
academies currently and it's something
that's done online they just sit down in
front of a computer and watch like a
it'd be like a one-hour refresher
training annually
all right thanks
there's also the case that
for recent graduates they would have
gotten the initial courses
which have been presented for a while i
don't know if it's five years or what
but there are some training already
correct
okay and the other representation
thank you madam chair i would just add
also i did
have a conversation with a couple of our
first responders on our committee and
i don't know if everyone's aware but if
there is a
traumatic incident that first responders
have to deal with they do have resources
available that they can
have counseling whatever their correct
word is
to
yes hurdles
as a matter of fact a former member of
this committee representative mark prue
is is one of the heads of the response
the state response team
any other questions comments concerns
okay then the motion is to adopt
amendment 1625 to senate bill 357
and the clerk can call the roll
representative lucas yes
representative murder
yes representative plett
we madame grafier yes
representative pearson
yeah absolutely yes representative
folsom yes
representative allegro
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative center
nostalgia yes representative goolie yes
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellow yes representative
yes
representative grota votes yes
representative gormallo yes
and the chair yes
19 to zero
okay
representative pearson you have a motion
i do thank you madam chair i move out of
pass
with amendment on senate bill three five
seven is there a second second
okay
do you have any more anything more to
add
um no i'm i'm uh quite proud of myself
as a somewhat of a closet procrastinator
that i've already submitted the majority
but thank you
yes
all right any further discussion or
comments
i have one question
you're repealing the commission to study
ptsd in a year
is that
a planned sunset or is it
yep so as as we have um
been drilled drilled into our heads by
the
house speaker we have so many committees
and commissions that exist that
we really do when we when we
move forward with any of them they
should have a sunset provision in them
okay thank you very much any other
questions or comments
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on senate
bill 357 and the clerk can call the roll
representative lucas yes representative
mirner yes representative plett yes
representative pearson
yes representative folsom yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative santo nostazo
yes representative goalie yes
representative
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative
yes
grotto votes yes representative gormallo
yes repre and the chair yes 19 to zero
right is there any objection to consent
seeing none we'll put that one on
okay
i'd like to bring up senate bill 383 the
land surveyors
and there is a
an amendment
that i hope you will accept
and i don't seem to have a copy there
oops yes i think that's it okay
second
this amendment came out of a
subcommittee work session
representative seitek is not with us
today so i got got to do the amendment
the
first thing we did is get rid of
roman 2 which was the paragraph that had
the
board can prosecute and judge
unlicensed practice because we were
we did
strengthen the last paragraph that the
actual alleged or suspected unlicensed
activities which
should cover any any incidents of
unlicensed practice
and they can report it to the attorney
general for prosecution
when they said that the
attorney general wasn't paying attention
the subcommittee decided that having an
official report from the
board of land surveyors rather than from
the professional organization would be
more effective in stirring them to
prosecute
and we hope that that will be the case
where
and we'll see what happens and see if
this helps
they also reported that the
registry of deeds is already required by
law to verify that any map they receive
is done by a licensed surveyor
so that eliminates some of the issue
and i didn't think trying to tell the
planning boards not to accept
casual maps
is
something that we can actually do in a
short period of time i think that's a
bill for another day that was at least
my conclusion
the part on a non-resident licensure is
cleaned up and put into
rsa
310a 69 which already deals with
non-resident
licensure and so what it does is that
the
requires the boards to be licensed in
another state
and has met the requirements for
licensure
the biggest and most significant of them
is the exam by the board
on the
truly weird and unique new hampshire
title issues
they need to know that if they're going
to work in the state
so they will be tested for that
and that as all land surveyors working
in the state are
and that's uh
then it takes place at the beginning of
let's see representative goalie
thank you madam chair well i was not
part of the subcommittee i did sit in
that day um and listen to the folks and
i i think we
came up
with good set of changes um removing the
penalties
um i think most people had questions as
to where up to ten thousand dollars
would go with the board as well as the
issue of there was really no place to
appeal the decision of the board um so
removing that section i think was the
right thing to do
um and also if we you know we're going
to remove the monetary penalties
increasing it to a class a misdemeanor
was also good with that
and uh the other changes i'm okay with
as well
any other comments questions
thank you man of chair well i'm glad to
see us do something i hope it's going to
be enough because
i i this is an issue that i've had some
dealings with in the past with land
surveying and i think that
the current situation is really
astonishingly
lax and irresponsible on the part of
the
state because a few things involving
property i think are more of
more significant than establishing
exactly where the heck it is
a
distance above sea level and so far
if you get it wrong it can have
serious
repercussions uh so i hope this is gonna
work the way we think it is because i
think this is a very big deal i i agree
and i think it it's a good start to have
the board investigate because
i mean they know what
surveying is and they know who's
licensed
any other comments questions
okay seeing none the motion is to adopt
amendment 1684
to house senate bill 383 and the clerk
can call the roll
representative lucas yes
representative mirner
yes representative plett yes
representative pearson
yes representative fulmson yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara yes
representative santo nostazo
yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes representative d
we showed
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative faulkner yes
the representative grota votes yes
representative gore milo yes and the
chair yes
19-0 all right we've adopted the
amendment i move out to pass with
amendment on senate bill 383 is there a
second
i think i've said enough representative
goalie
okay any other comments questions or
concerns
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on senate
bill 383
remember
representative lucas yes representative
mirner yes representative plett yes
representative pearson
yes representative thompson
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative center
nostalgia
yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative
schmidt aye
representative marsh yes represent
fellows yes representative
yes
representative grotto votes yes
representative gore malo yes and the
chair yes
19 to zero
any objections to consent
all right seeing none we'll put that one
on consent also
excellent
uh
senate bill 282 representative leckus
folks of universe and marsh you have an
amendment in the in a motion
yes i do matter chair and uh
let me pass these around for anybody who
this sub amendment comes out of the
subcommittee
what happened is that
the
house bill that this was the companion
to apparently resulted in some
disagreement amongst the acupuncturists
and we got them all together with the
subcommittee and agreed upon language
the biggest change which brought
everybody to agreement was changing line
seven
uh where we added as a third way of
getting a license a prior ncc aom
certification with documentation of
continuing education
pursuant to paragraph 10 which is the
continuing education portion of the
statute
we also made a number of other minor
changes to the bill we changed oriental
medicine to asian medicine in a number
of places
and we
updated the names of the a c a h m
and the uh
ncc aom and added the phrase including
its predecessors and successors in order
to avoid having to amend the statute if
they just changed their name
so i ask you all to support 1596-h
i wanted to say something about the
contingency language because this is
important for new members uh what we did
is we made this bill take effect one
minute after house bill 1192 so that it
will overwrite
house bill 1192 which already went
through this committee and that way
there will be no
uh conflict
so thank you thank you for addressing
that so clearly representative blackis
uh thank you yes this uh we got together
with uh acupuncture practitioners and
the uh
the board
and um thrashed through the details and
got uh
agreement i'd like to thank
representative marsh for for dealing
with some of those details
and there was a sufficient agreement i
don't know about the rest of the
subcommittee but i got a very nice thank
you card in the mail so i urge you to
adopt this amendment please okay
okay the motion is to adopt amendment
to senate bill 282 in the clerk and call
the wall
representative electrics yes
representative murder yes representative
plett yes representative pearson yes
representative fulmsum yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzarra yes representing santo nestaso
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative
yes representative wrote a vote yes
representative gore milo yes and the
chair yes
19 to 0.
all right in that case representative
marsh you have a motion my motion is
ought to pass as amended and uh i think
i've said enough
and i'll second okay
by representing mars seconded by
representative leckus
any any comments questions or discussion
uh no yeah from him
we've said enough i think
okay thank you thank you for that
if there's no other discussion
the motion is uh to pass with amendment
on senate bill 282 and the clerk can
call the role representative lucas yes
representative mirner yes representative
plett yes representative pearson yes
representative folmsome yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative santo nastaso
yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellow yes representative faulkner yes
representative grotto votes yes
representative gore malo yes
and the chair yes
19 to zero
are there any objections to consent
seeing none
uh and that's folks and marshall all
right if he hasn't already
we'll be on consent
all right
senate bill 277 representative bailey
i'm trying to what's the number of the
amendment that's what i'm trying to find
um it's
16.95
correct yes 16.95
um
if
there was some disagreement over it
related to
whether or not there was a category
of student nurses that could be extended
but
nevertheless the amendment passed the
committee
um
is there a second
yeah i'll second it okay do please just
uh so we
uh discussed this bill this morning and
the um one the question was about the
senior nursing students and whether or
not
by passing this we would have uh
we would you know make another window
where
new
nurses could uh
could get licensed without you know
emergency license without um
taking a exam
um
but
uh based on testimony we heard uh
because this has a may issue if there
was some sort of loophole like that in
okay
and the economic representative goalie
and then marsh
thank you madam chair um i will support
the amendment after voting against it um
in subcommittee
i
still question
why ols wrote the amendment the way they
did and couldn't use the language that
was
in the current bill in front of them in
front of them that they wrote beforehand
and just changed the date to
july 31st 2023 like we had asked that
they decided they needed to put in the
whole
um
first section of the bill that
includes the
temporary hill partner
includes the um
definition for
student nursing and all that
in there from the
what was
chaptered law that i had dan pull up for
me so i could review it
that was the current emergency language
um that they chose all of a sudden that
they needed to put in this bill versus
just changing the date um but in just
doing that um and reviewing it i'm
comfortable with it now um that i don't
believe it'll include any
other student nurses going forward it's
just those that are currently licensed
under this statute thank you
okay thank you representative marsh yes
thank you uh unlike representative
goalie i'm afraid i cannot support this
amendment and the reason why i've got to
go slightly into the weeds as to how
continuing medical education works for
physicians if you look at lines 12-14
and lines 22-24 what this amendment says
is not withstanding any law rule to the
contrary a medical provider should not
be required to complete continuing
education as the condition
precedent to reactivating your license
or
getting an emergency license
the way the continuing education
cycle works for physicians in the state
of new hampshire it's a two-year cycle
so when a doctor does give up his
license he
most often has not done continuing
education for two years
possibly three because he could have
done all of his continuing education in
the first year of the prior cycle
then we're giving them a three year time
period whereby they can reactivate their
license and then if they get a license
they have another two year cycle before
they have to finish completing any
medical education
if i add those numbers up that makes
either seven or eight years during which
time a physician would not be required
to do any continuing medical education
whatsoever i believe that is a threat to
the public health and not in the best
interests of the citizens of the state
of new hampshire so i will be voting
against this amendment and if adopted i
will vote against the bill
thank you very much any other comments
questions
okay not seeing any other representative
schmidt
i think we ought to uh
consider very carefully uh
yes
it
that section is not unique to physicians
it's any medical provider which includes
everybody from
occupational therapists on up
so i'm
um
what would you suggest
uh madam chair i'm not as familiar with
their continuing education requirements
because i have not lived their life but
i have a question okay
um
pearson
i'm just trying to make sure that we
have not
also included emergency medical
technicians in this
because that that would be substantially
problematic are they considered medical
providers they carry medical property
well they carry licenses by the state i
just don't know i don't know that it
necessarily falls under this statute so
they're not under the office of
professional licensure and certification
they're under the
department of safety correct they are
under the department of safety so i
representative goalie
thank you manager uh
my guess and i would
strongly i believe that
they would not fall into this they are
not licensed by oak plc these are all
licensees that i believe were through
oplc and dealing with where as you
stated
emts are through department of safety
yeah 3310 is oplcs okay
thank you
the license the continuing education for
physicians
we don't require continuing education
for someone who gets an initial license
do we
well you're required to pass an exam and
complete medical school
well these things there's nothing to it
yeah
no but if you are say a practicing
physician in another state
we don't require any special
continuing education before
giving them a new hampshire license do
we
i don't know the answer to that question
i can tell you what it was uh 35 years
ago when i got my license i don't think
that's wrong i would suspect that is no
represented maybe we ought to pull this
off the
agenda for the moment and
move to things where where we don't have
questions outstanding well
i what i need to do is make sure that we
proceed with it because
i'm not willing to accept the bill as
written
and
if the rest of the committee is not
willing to accept this amendment we've
got
mr tory could you find out what the
continuing education requirements are
for physicians coming here from another
state
yes representative
thank you madam chair i also just
so the committee knows that this also
states that
um
oplc may
produce a license for these individuals
it doesn't say they shall so there still
is discretion there as to where they're
qualified
well
i that's nice to know but i'm if the if
the committee is seriously concerned
that we want to require
continuing education or some education
or even a note that they
they must complete continuing education
within six months of getting that
license which might be one way to do it
um
like us
i i was just going to ask if
if representative marsh had some
suggestion on how to change this that
would
satisfy him
i would be satisfied if they were
current on their continuing education at
the time of being reissued a license
and some language to that effect could
certainly be drafted
okay thank you okay thank you
all right we'll we will in fact take a
recess on this
after rep after mr tory reports to us
representing marsh i'll be looking for a
change to this amendment that we can
discuss and then go for a final
amendment
okay
moving right along
let's see where's my amendment on i have
you haven't
give us a number it i believe it's 16 45
correct 1645 okay i move amendment
1645 to
this amendment is almost identical to
the non-germane amendment we heard
to
expand jail car
except that it corrects the number of
members of each party that are going to
be appointed
per representative goalie's request
because i
and i will say
well first is there a second
i'll second it okay thank you i was
waiting for that all right and i i will
comment that
improvements based on this amendment
the first
and most obvious and important
is that each member of jail card will
have one third of the total work
that
members have now and i think that's
going to be really important in terms of
recruitment and retention
the current workload means that if
you're
really diligent you can skim through
most of the the rules before the meeting
i read fast but i can't get through the
entire packet every every time
and so i would expect that having a
lesser workload would make it easier for
the p to people to
review the review the rules in front of
them and
do a better job with them
uh the second advantage is that we'll
get more members of the house
involved in the rulemaking process
and i think that will help them to take
it more seriously we get we keep trying
to get other people on committees other
than the edna to take rules seriously
but it is
it's an uphill battle i think if we have
more people who are not on the edna
involved on jail car and reading the
rules they will understand how important
it is
and therefore be more involved
and the third reason is that it's
possible
in rare cases that a member would have
some knowledge of
legislative intent or the
business that
the
the staff doesn't have
and you know really this isn't going to
happen very often but once in a while
it'll be useful
it'll be particularly handy in cases
where we have conflicting statutes which
comes up more
more often than you would think
they try to write the rule and they say
well you know this the statute says this
but this other statute says something
else
it hap and getting that kind of
problem resolved is
always a
hard to do elegantly so i would support
that representative pearson
thank you man chair and uh the other
thing too is
as far as looking at the structure of
this i mean this is an in this is fairly
similar to how we broke up finance
with the uh
because of due to their workload with
the
you know just just as a reminder on the
top of page two it does just talk about
the authorities and how when the full
committee
is involved and whatnot so
um
i think with the also too with the
situation now where rules have
expiration dates and they have to be re
reviewed
we're we're getting ourselves into a
situation where jail car is going to
become
literally a full-time job so without
this i can tell you without this there's
zero chance i'd ever want to be on jail
car so
i i think this is this is definitely
necessary and i fully support it okay
other comments or questions
representative schuett
thank you madam chair um
as an alternate member of job carr
we heard during the hearing on this
non-german amendment that this is
something that leadership was looking at
for some time
however
it was brought to us practically the
last minute as a non-germane amendment
on a bill that has nothing to do with
the subject matter
if it's been looked at for so long why
were we not seeing it as
a standalone bill that could be examined
more thoroughly
i think there could be
some good issues in this i agree with
expanding
to more membership however i think
i think we need to look at it a little
more deeply
i would prefer to not adopt this
amendment or if we adopt the amendment
end up putting the bill in interim study
so that it can be looked at more deeply
this was actually intended to be a
perfectly germane amendment on the bill
we had on the rule making process
but the deadline slipped before we i
could schedule before i could deal with
it so this was intended to be an
amendment to a house bill on the jail
car process which we had
and this was the first
opportunity we had to deal with it
i i do appreciate that however like i
said i i would have even
thought that it could have been brought
forward as a bill a standalone bill
uh unfortunately the speaker didn't talk
to me until after until well after the
well but i will say that this year is
unusual
in that it's
the first time on edna
that i've seen that we haven't had any
bills trying to tweak the rulemaking
process other than that one
um
that we
didn't want to use
and
you know it it's not that like this is a
surprise people have been complaining
that the rules don't quite meet
legislative intent
or their
the agencies are doing things
out of line
so i
i would say that you sh it shouldn't
have been a surprise
and that this is a fairly modest change
it doesn't change the procedure except
by splitting up the workload and that's
why i thought that was the most
important
issue to bring forward that the work
particularly this coming session when
all the the rules the first 10 year
rules are expiring
so there's going to be a lot of rules
coming through and i think having
a third of the workload is a very
anyone else representing fellows
um yeah i had two thoughts about this
bill um
one is i'm i'm not
sure that
adding another layer to the process is
going to help eliminate the the workload
that much because if you've got
divisions then it raises questions about
when does the public testify do they
testify to the division and then testify
again when you have the whole group
or um
the only time that the entire board has
to get together if there is a final
objection and a petition to the house
well when does the public testify
at
the public hearing on the rule
in front of the agency is the most
appropriate time or they could testify
so they that would be just a subgroup of
the people who are going to act on it so
i have no no the that would be the only
action
unless there's a final objection
gelcar is a filter more than anything
else
it's
they say
the assumption in jalakar is that the
agency has done its job it has written
the rules correctly
and if it's and so we we just bless it
and it goes into effect the only way we
can stop
stop a rule is by a
final objection to the whole house and
triggered by testimony that is heard
that's correct and if that were to
happen then the entire jail car would
meet to to consider that
and so i would say that somebody would
get three bites at the apple
before the
agency before the uh division and before
the final uh
objection
so well that that was just you know
no i agree it's a concern
and the other thing is
it seems to me that it would be useful
to have a study committee look at this
and then we could get input from the
agencies who have to write the rules
and the people on gelcar
and um
the public or or organizations that that
sometimes testify before jail car just
i'm just concerned about something that
that is pretty has a pretty delicate
balance in terms of being able to get
through the process right now
that
if we're going to make changes we want
to make sure that we do all the right
changes that are needed
thank you any other comments or
questions
so i think that uh
there are a number of incorrect
assumptions that work here
or misunderstandings
and having served on the jail car now
for
16 years
i think i have some level of
understanding of the entire process
and
i think
some of the concerns are simply
wrong-headed to the degree that
there may be
mis
misapplication of the rules or
a heavy-handedness on the part of
agencies or departments
uh this uh rewrite uh will not prevent
that
i think that
the idea of
getting into something as significant as
this
without having heard a word of testimony
from
scott eaton who basically created
the administrative rules unit
some 35 years ago
and who served until about two months
ago
as is the executive director of the
administrative rules unit
and we also have the current acting
director who's also been
the
um
a member of the administrative rules or
unit
he didn't get to testify
and i think a study committee to look at
the real issues
and there are some
that
could
definitely
stand
have
an examination by a study committee i i
wouldn't object to that at all
because it can never hurt to look at
things even if they've been in effect
for a long time but here we are
launching into
uh you know a significant rewrite
uh with
some assumptions that the
model of the the finance committee where
divisions are absolutely necessary
but where the
full committee does vote on
is a bad
analogy that's really not the way gel
car works and the idea that you're going
to have
the the divisions
make decisions just means that
two-thirds of the gel car won't have
seen
uh you know a particular rule set
at all
uh unless there's a final objection
which there rarely is
there
it's nothing is more common with gel car
other than stuff that goes through on
the consent calendar
um
uh
then for the committee to file a
preliminary
objection the first time the rule comes
before the jail card
it's
a virtual
certainty that
that
there will be preliminary objections
which then
gives the agency the slash department 45
days
to come up with a a solution that is not
objectionable
and ordinarily that's what happens
the agency slash department comes back
in the
within that 45-day period with wording
that
will find approval
from the gel car
and so i think this is rushed
i think it's flawed i think it's
wrong-headed in terms of its
understanding of the process
uh where in point of fact the
the chair has already correctly
enunciated that the rules the assumption
is that the rules will be well written
by the agency slash department
and generally they are and they are the
rules are written uh you know in
conjunction with the stakeholders slash
practitioners
there's a public hearing to
to hear that
preliminary rule
and
work is done in that in that
in that context as well and
when it comes to us the second time
to the jail car
you know we have another public hearing
and
i think the process works
extraordinarily well
and
that doesn't mean that i would object to
looking at it in in line with some
criticisms that have been raised but i
think many of the criticisms and i've
heard them over and over again in my 20
years in the house
that the agencies or departments are
running amok
they're running wild they're there they
have plenary authority to do whatever
they want
that's complete balderdash
hogwash and and ridiculous
the agencies and departments
are bound by their rules and to the
degree that they are heavy-handed
on some occasions we had one here in
this committee with the remember the
clamshack
people
that had to put in this massive
uh grease trap uh
as a result of an order from the from
the des
i i i had to miss the first half of the
hearing you know what it's like when you
come in and halfway through a movie and
you're trying to figure out what's going
on
uh but but nevertheless i i i didn't
think that there was a real argument
that the agency had overstepped its
authority but that's not going to be
solved by this rewrite at all
the agency is always uh
you know potentially going to be
going too far
but but we haven't had if we had regular
examples of that
then i would say we we would need to fix
that
not the rules themselves
um so again i don't want to talk this to
death and that's not my intention i just
think that that this has
amend that statement a very low
percentage chance of passing the senate
just think about it
this rewrite would put 12 members of the
senate
on jail card either as regular members
or alternates
that's half the senate
if it were 12 members of the house which
it will be
or maybe it's a few more i'm i may be
misremembering that
that's what in a 400 member house
that's a fraction
whereas the reality is not only would it
involve
half the senate
but virtually all the senators at one
point or another have been on the have
been on the jail car
so they all have experience
and i and i don't think that they will
think that this is uh workable at all
and we haven't heard from
the public we haven't heard from
the members of the administrative rules
unit as i said
so there's just no way in hell that i'm
going to vote
for this and i'm going to fight it if it
if it passes this committee
and if it passes the house i'll continue
to fight it because i think it's a
solution in search of a problem thank
you representative schmidt i appreciate
your honesty i will say that having only
served 12 years on jail car
i i'm more concerned about the fact that
it is my experience that very few
members actually read the rules they
don't know what questions to ask because
there's a stack like this
my goal is to bring down the stack so
that
the
the rules will be looked at that's all i
am not saying anything that will stop
the agencies from
going too far i mean i was probably on
jail car when we passed that thousand
gallon tank
and you were too
but we didn't it wasn't flagged by by
the staff and neither of us knew enough
about it to say a thousand gallon grease
tank
all right
i i mad i'm sure i doubt that came to
the job card all that was an action of
the de this is in their rules it's not
in the law the thousand gallon tank is
an action it's a rule of the of des it's
in their
rules specifically and it doesn't say
any and if we had thought about it if we
had realized god that's an enormous
grease trap
we could have said you know unless
and when the des was here they say well
we we can make allowances
except their rule has no place for
allowances
all right so i think that the
that just a little more knowledge might
be very helpful and having a shorter
stack of rules to read
is going would be extremely helpful and
that's why i'm pushing that as the major
advantage yes the senate will be
will be an issue and we'll have to deal
with that but
well a little more knowledge i think is
a very
wise statement and i think this
committee with regard to this
non-tremaine amendment which has you
know had precious little
hearing and precious little involvement
it was properly noticed and announced
and available in advance and
specifically mentioned
it was about jail car
and the administrative rules agency
decided not to send anybody even for
information purposes
so i my
i'm i'm used to dealing with the
agencies and my assumption is if they
don't show up
they're okay with it maybe not but maybe
not significantly in support but they
don't have any serious objections or
they would have been at the hearing
but i'm pretty sure it was not the case
and not i'm not challenge your belief
our opinions are
are set and we don't need to discuss it
represent goalie you have a comment
thank you madam chair i will be
supporting this um
[Music]
i come from the philosophy that
more eyes overseeing something is always
better
um and
lessening a workload of those few is
always better
um
it creates a better product
creates greater oversight
and i think that's important
as many of us know
legislation that's passed here
and number of it goes through the
rule-making process
and
most people don't follow that through
and there are times when
those rules that are written for
legislation can have more of an effect
than the legislation itself
when it's written
so
i believe having more eyes
and having less of a workload on those
individuals on gelcar
will make sure that those rules put in
place
follow the law that was written
so for that reason i'll be supporting
this thank you
thank you any other comments or
questions representative marsh
yes i have to admit that i'm a little
bit of a quandary here i've never been
on gelcar however the comment that the
senate's not likely to get along with
this certainly sounds like the senate to
me the senate is usually very good at
reducing the number of senators on bills
that we send to them and i think if we
pass this we should expect this to go to
committee of conference and that will
probably get worked out
uh yes i will mention that on jail car
for the house alternates to fill the
senate seats other than the chair or
vice chairs the case may be
certainly
the
it is rare we have a full complement of
senators
okay
any other comments concerns
okay then the motion is to adopt
amendment 1645 to senate bill 358
and uh the clerk can call the roll
representative lucas yes representative
mirner
yes representative plett yes
representative peterson yes
representative folsom yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative santo anastasio yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
no
representative
representative schmidt
no
i know but i had to ask
reluctantly no
representing fellows no
representative faulkner
no
representative broder votes yes
representative gormallo
yes
and the chair
it is 14 to 5.
all right the amendment is adopted
i move ought to pass with amendment i'll
second that madam chair okay
and i think i've said enough
yeah it's a rewrite so we've covered it
okay any further discussion comments
questions
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on senate
bill 358 and if it's not 14 to 5 i'm
yes
okay
representative mirner yes representative
plett yes representative pearson yes
representative folmsome yes
representative electro yes
representative bailey
representative lanzara
president santo nostalso yes
representative goalie yes representative
stewart
representative schmidt sounds like we
okay
okay representative schmidt
no
representative marsh
no representative fellows now
representative fautner no
representative groeder votes yes
representative gormallo yes
and the chair
yes guess what
it's 14 to 5.
and your motion will be what to
represent
yes yes yes yes
test
so how about there we go we had we
probably had too many on
anyway so representative grota suggests
we consider senate bill
226 which is the recruit
i moved back to pass
representative fellow moves ought to
pass is there a second
it's not i think it's not working again
um anyway um i think
that
we have heard in nobody disputes that
there's a difficulty
filling positions for state workers
and in some cases it's very difficult
to fill some key positions and and one
that we've heard about more than once is
filling
uh vacancies at the state prison
so while i don't think
this bill will
make any
long-term improvements
i think that it will prevent the
situation from becoming worse at some of
those key places like like in the in
corrections and if we don't pass it
um
the the shortage
of
um corrections officers will just become
worse and even more people will just
want to quit so i think that just as a
stop gap
uh representative brodar do you wish to
speak
no i would not thank you
yes representative pearson
thank you madam chair
the
we did hear from
one of the agencies that that this has
been somewhat
uh this somewhat been going on for a
little bit
because the the the crisis the problem
that we have which which uh various
agencies have is it varies obviously
from agency to agency i know that we're
you know we're 68 state troopers short
right now we're hundreds of corrections
officers short
and
the alarming
realization that especially in the doc
they're spending 16 million dollars of
overtime
and we have one one state person so um
we have the men and the women yeah
one one for each um but the
you know looking at this i i think that
it's um
i think it just kind of kind of codifies
what what they're doing
haphazardly in some cases right now and
uh
and i hope that this actually does
bear some realistic fruit from the from
the deep dive so
i can i'm certainly supportive of this
anyone anyone anyone else
personally yeah i'm just going to
express a concern i know it's not going
to impact the way that this is voted but
i just have this sneaking suspicion that
um
well as representative peterson said
they've been doing this kind of
haphazardly for a while
i think we're throwing money at a
project that
ain't gonna make a difference i mean i
think there are probably deeper problems
than
uh what have been stated in the
testimony that we're heard
and they're not gonna be taken care of
in the short term
just by throwing a little bit more money
at it but like i said i'm not going to
go on because
i'm probably going to wind up supporting
this but um i do so hesitantly
okay representative schuett
thank you madam chair i will say that
there was an article
in the news over the weekend that the
doc has
[Music]
i'm not quite sure what the word is
recruited
parole and probation officers to come in
and assist
doing doc officer
positions
which is a pretty extreme
reaction but obviously needed
i agree with representative allegro i'm
not sure if this is
going to make that large a difference
but at least they are attempting to do
something
and i think we can support that and
i would hope that going forward
that this legislature would look at
perhaps increasing
the pay scale for
unfortunately the pay scale for
corrections officers is determined
primarily by their their contract and we
have almost no control over that
that's only for the executive the
non-classified employees the classified
employees are
in covered by the contract
and i will point out that
our state employees went for quite some
time without a contract trying to
negotiate
better benefits and better pay so that's
i'll leave it at that yeah
anyone else represent bailly
again i don't necessarily think it would
make me oppose it but i don't know that
we ever heard anything
that
identified or showed that
the problems the state the hiring
problems the state is having are any
different than those in the market at
large
if if you want some i can give you some
i'll give you i'll give you a glowing
example that the city of worcester under
massachusetts civil service law has to
post their hiring list there's 276
people on worcester fire's hiring list
there are 35 firefighters in the state
of new hampshire period on a hiring list
not not manchester not nashua the entire
state so this is very much a new
hampshire problem
where this
where in massachusetts they they are not
seeing this
well you're talking about other state
governments i mean the market at large
has a overall problem of staffing and is
this really any different sure but
there's a you know there's a direct
correlation some of these jobs that
we're looking at are are by definition
government jobs so you know we don't
really have you know private prisons and
we don't really have private police
departments and things like that so so i
think there is a direct correlation as
the new england
region as we are is
from a from a human resources standpoint
is very much regional and we do compete
and i would like to mention that it
appears that this is the
first time they can throw money at the
problem even if it's
with
by going through fiscal and getting some
money
and some of their ideas involve money
some don't
but i think
that's always
something to consider because i know
that the private sector is creating
yeah mcdonald's and dairy has got a 500
sign-on bonus i i've never seen that in
my life
but they didn't feel the need to
have a special program they just
yeah any other comments
representative platt it's not going to
involve my vote at all i think i'm for
this but uh
it's not only pay its working conditions
i don't
in the state prison can't be great i'll
just leave it there and i used to go
into the state prison all the time
because there was a jc chapter in there
i go visit him it was not fun
yes thank you
many of us have been to the state prison
and we're aware it is not the most
pleasant place i'll just note that it
was all
none of it was against our will just for
the record yeah i was going to say as
visitors
yes exactly we were visitors
all right anyone else how clear i was a
i will say that having a previous
conviction is not a bar to being elected
as a state representative
so any other comments my conviction was
for insanity
it's
no we were in the secure psychiatric
unit
anyone else
all right ella having no
no other questions the motion is ought
to pass on senate bill 226 by
representative philos
the clerk can call the role
representative lucas yes representative
murder yes representative plett yes
representative pearson yes
representative fulmson yes president of
lake bro yes representative bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
represents santo nostazo yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes representative founder yes
representative ots representative
gormallo yes and the chair what happened
to her
did anybody
object to consent
no
okay
bill this oh sorry
this was for the handout that we that
the only one that
we don't have an amendment
you have yours okay
okay representative 397
representative pearson
has an amendment
thank you madam chair i have an
i just want to verify the number is 1725
is that right it is 1759
ah
madam chair i also won 1725 which i'll
oh lovely and representative allegro has
so yes we have three different
amendments to this we will discuss them
in order that won't make this
complicated at all
now
we will discuss amendment
1759 which is representative pearson's
amendment
and then we will consider other
amendments
madam chair do we know if if the three
counteract the others or
will they work in conjunction
we don't we will deal with that when we
see them i haven't seen representative
marsha's amendment
did you say
you have madam chair senator carson's
amendment made as a house amendment
oh okay
so no they do no they do not work
together because representative
pearson's amendment makes changes beyond
representative marsha's amendment so i
think we should consider his first
can we please heaven what are the three
amendments i just want to make i'm
missing one there's one from marsh one
from pearson and one from allegro
mark have you passed them out or will
you
oh they're right here
sorry
oh my god
representative allegro's amendment would
work with either of the other two but
those two do not work with each other do
you have a legend no i don't thank you
yes
i can explain
right representative pearson you go
first
thank you madam chair um wait is there a
second to your amendment
oh second all right just for the sake of
discussion yes okay thank you so
the amendment um that that i'm bringing
forward does this
okay the bill itself 397
part one involves a compact
for mental health
counseling
the second part of the bill which is i
believe starts on page
19 involves an
compact
and that's what that's what the the the
actual bill is it does two things what
my amendment does is my amendment
retains the mental health compact
portion and removes the interstate
compact for the placement of children
what it also does is it includes
the critical items that
children in family law was concerned
right so the
reason being
for this
is that the
the second part of this the interstate
compact for the placement of children
has existed for 13 years
in it and it is not getting traction
it requires 35 states in order to be
enacted and they haven't even cleared a
third of that yet
in 13 years so clearly there's not an
appetite
by the by the various states
to get into that particular type of
compact the current compact we have was
created in somewhere between 1960 and
it
certainly has some things in it that
aren't working
the
carson slash marsh amendment um has
sections in it that fix a couple of
immediate needs
that the children and family law
committee saw
so my amendment retains those critical
items and just dumps the the rest of a
compact that frankly i don't think will
okay and i will add that
this
part is what the chip the committee on
children and family law which we invited
to participate in our
subcommittee
actually i invited them to for the
hearing but they didn't
and the governor considered to be
crucial to enact this year so
i would hope you will support that
representative marsh
uh yes i will point out that when we
heard testimony on the interstate
compact for the placement of children
the department of health and human
services told us that currently it's
been enacted by between 17 and 20 states
that's considerably more than had
enacted it last year when it came before
health and human services
nevertheless uh the representative
pearson is quite correct that the
threshold of 35 is quite high and it may
be a number of years before we reach
that threshold that i would take issue
with the statement that uh there are not
more states adopting it because there
yeah and i will we'll add that if we
unless we are entirely happy with the
revision there is no need to pass it
this year because it is extremely
unlikely that the additional 15 states
will proceed to adopt it
any other comments or questions
representative platt question of
representative pearson if we were to
retain the second part of the bill with
the interstate compact that means we
have to swallow a whole language
for the compact
so the way compacts work in the in
despite the fact that this is a 37 page
document
is con interstate compacts are go no go
we can't
amend the terms of them it's either we
agree to get into them
some of these compacts especially if
you're in the door early
to entice states to join you you now sit
on a rules committee where the where the
some of those things occur
um
the
placement of children if
representative marsha's numbers are
correct which they probably are we're
going to be past the we'll pass the
initial dangling of the gold coin so we
would just be a member in that case the
mental health compact
um
is now
initially had five states that had
entered it is now at nine it takes ten
to ratify
this is a compact that actually will
happen and it actually will happen if
yeah i think i just understood that
right that if you're in on this early
um you potentially get more say
and so what we're doing here is seeding
some of our own ability to set rules for
our own business and behavior but
i i have to what bothers me about this
process right here that we're talking
about is
we're trying to make excuses we're
saying it yes 35 is a high bar it's
probably not going to happen and so on
and so forth
ruling by i'm sorry legislating by
roulette
i don't think is
the way to go here i think that there
are objections enough objections to both
parts of this bill
that i'm going to have great difficulty
supporting either
i think okay well this amendment deletes
section two so you should be happy with
that
representative blackist and then folsom
yeah i agree with representative eliagro
and i'm a general skeptical of compacts
otherwise my support in general what
they're trying to do
so i'm going to support this um part of
my concern is that
this came as an amendment late in the
day to a senate bill
and you know
i would like to have uh certainly more
of a look at this and uh hear from more
people on the details of this compact
representative folsom
thank you um
last year we saw this come before health
and human services as part of a 72-part
omnibus bill
and at that point i argued against its
passage in saying that it needed to go
before child and family law
i see that they've now attached it to
another part um it worries me that they
can't they don't think that it can stand
alone as a bill and i think that that's
what it has to have i believe once we
enter into this compact
we
cede a lot of our authority of our
children over to the federal government
and
because the rules are then set by
a person that has been appointed by the
commissioner of health and human
services from our state to go
vote we don't know those 35 states that
are going to be voting we don't know if
they're like our state
and
the financing is also not described in
here
in that each member state shall
establish a central state compact office
and it goes on
and at first i
was
thought that it was a general state
compact office for the state but when
you start looking at how they define
things they want a state office just for
this compact
um and there's no fiscal note regarding
that and then also
the rules committee once it is
established will decide on how the all
the work will be financed
and that the states will be required to
help finance that
it also talks about data collection and
sharing among various agencies and
states
and uh we have we have some
pretty strong opinions in our state
about privacy and
i don't know that we want to hand over
to
at least 34 other states a decision on
what we feel our citizens have said is
privacy
um and so
uh
you know that's just that's just an
overview of some of the things that i've
i i'm concerned about this concept so
you're in favor of this amendment i am
very in favor of this amendment okay
other comments
i'd like to say that i agree with
representative folsom and that the
compact doesn't
i wouldn't accept the compact without a
great deal of concern because if nothing
else it gives
rule-making authority to an unelected
body
which is against our state constitution
we can delegate that but it we cannot
have a rule imposed by this compact
board that is
has the effect of law in the compact
states
anyway other questions comments concerns
okay represent bail
we've got three amendments here and you
said one one aspect of this was some
kind of huge priority
uh which one gives us that and not the
both representative marsha's amendment
and representative pearson's amendment
include the language that the governor
and the children and family law found
vital
okay the difference is that
representative pearson's amendment
removes
the interstate
compact from the bill
is that correct versus marsh uh yes okay
so
so we will consider the pearson
amendment
after if it passes we will go on to the
allegro amendment if it does not pass we
will consider the march amendment
because
um
it's one or the other that's reasonable
okay
so the the question is to adopt the
pearson amendment
1759 to senate bill 397
which deletes
the interstate comment compact on the
placement of children the 2009 version
and adds in the protection of placement
of a child with the parent
mr pearson can you in just one sentence
could you just
i'm sorry but this is all coming on at
the last moment in just one sentence can
you
if you uh talk to my mother you'll
understand that i can't do anything in
one sentence
so here he said it's already one so
here's what i'll tell you what the
amendment does this is a two-part piece
of legislation 397. it removes the
entire second part
gone
totally dispatches of it and then what
it does is it tacks on the part that
we've been discussing um that is
critical to both child and family law
and the governor's office in reference
to current situations
that is um that will fix something in
the 1960 compact that we're already in
that is extraordinarily problematic
so this bill goes from being
two compacts
to being one compact and some new
provisions correct thank you that is
correct
any other any other questions discussion
all right seeing none
the motion is to adopt the
pearson amendment 15
1759 h to senate bill 397 and the clerk
can call the rule
representative lucas yes
representative murder yes representative
plett yes representative pearson yes
representative folsom yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative center nostalgia yes
representative goalie
no
representative stewart
representative
no no
representative schmidt no representative
marsh no representing fellows
no
representative no
president grotaphone snow representative
gormallo
no
okay one two three
it's ten to nine
okay
find the
the pearson amendment passes
and the so we will not consider the
marsh amendment we will go on to the
mark you will make a motion
um yes i uh well obviously i propose his
amendment um
and
it does
two things from my point of view
one is it it addresses what we just did
for part one for part two for part one
it simply removes the interstate compact
on mental health
that satisfies me because again
um
several people have made the point that
we're seeding
our authority
to other states
but as i said i would be remiss if i
didn't say
what i said on friday
i see language in here that is very
bothersome to me
i understand that this is embedded
in most
professional
societies and boards and
employment places
and that's language on
insisting
on
uh training in i don't remember the
precise words now
cultural diversity
whatever it
was we have a law in this state
that addresses divisive concepts
anyone and everyone could sit here in
this room and tell me oh it's a
different thing this is cultural
diversity
i have seen too many times
and i am guessing that most of the
people in this room have seen too many
times
that this is a moving target
and that
the terms
cultural diversity or whatever it was in
this one
is just a euphemism
or
dare i say the words critical race
theory
i cannot and i will not
in the future ever again
support anything that violates the
language of hb 544 that we passed in
is there a second
no second okay
i just want to make sure we're talking
about amendment 17 35 h correct
yes
all right
thank you
do you wish to speak to your second yes
i uh i certainly support um
what representative elieger i think is
trying to do but i actually do have a
question
which is sort of a
mechanical question into how
this will fit together with um
uh
i see that it'll get rid of one and two
and it will replace three and four which
basically gets rid of them with this
contingency but the question is will it
leave in
uh
the additional language that was added
by the other prior amendment we adopted
no it will not it will override the
um
so yes we would
if we pass this amendment i we will need
to discuss whether we need a
corrected amendment that includes
that new language from the pearson
amazing okay i will uh
so this amendment essentially deletes
counselors
can i just clarify something
so f if both of these amendments pass
we've deleted both compacts but we
haven't really resolved the issue
that we need to resolve is that correct
that's why i think we need to
consider
reinserting the language of the pearson
amendment
because
and leave that as the only content of
the bill if we pass this amendment also
i will recommend that we do so because
that's that's important
okay so it's we're adopting amendment
1735 to senate bill 397 representative
lucas yes representative murder
no
representative decide oh sorry
representative plett no
representative pearson no
representative folsom yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzara
no representative santo nostazo yes
representative goalie no representative
stewart
no representative d no sherman
representative schmidt
no representative marsh no
representative fellows no representative
founder no representative grotevo to
know representative gormallo
no
and the chair
yes
it's a six six to thirteen
amendment fails
the amendment fails 6 to 13.
so representative pearson you have a
a motion i do i i do have a motion on
senate bill 397 otp with amendment
1759 h
the pearson amendment
okay
with the pearson amendment which
replaces the interstate compact for
children with the specific language that
we want to adopt so it's otpa
with amendment 1759
okay
you wish to speak to your motion
uh we've we've certainly covered um
what what my amendment does to the bill
and uh so i don't think there's anything
else to say
all right any other comments
for the record i won't support this
because i do think that the 1960s
version needs to be replaced badly and
and i intend to have a minority report
reflect that fact
so you are you are not supporting it you
are opposing it i will i will oppose
otpa because i think that we need a
all right
the motion is ought to pass with the
pearson amendment on senate bill 397 and
representative lucas no
representative
murder yes
representative plett yes
representative pearson yes
representative folsom yes
representative allegro no
representative bailey
no representative lonzara yes
representative santo anastaso yes
no representative schuett
no
representative schmidt no representative
marsh no representative fellows
no representative
no representative groter votes no
gormallo representative gore milo no and
the chair
yes
uh that is
interesting
um
i think i'm going to recess this and let
people ponder it and we will come back
it's a it's a concern
okay
uh representative allegro you have a
it's recessing this one yes i move itl
on on sb224
second
okay
what is the name of the bill can you say
what bill it is again
this is the
children's environmental health day
no
is there a second by anyone represent
okay
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
yes thank you um i have a couple or a
few reasons why i
am not in support of this bill
the one that i think
resonates most with this committee
is the idea that we shouldn't be in the
business of creating memorial days
and i think we've rejected virtually
virtually every one of them this year
um
so that's
my number one concern the the other was
i was very surprised this morning to see
nobody
in testimony supporting unless i'm
forgetting
nobody showed up
so i don't think there's
a
great amount of interest in this to
begin with and i
i don't like adding legislation to the
uh basically what he said is good
hey
representative flatt to say enough that
with enough of these memorial days
they won't be memorable
that's been our position thank you
any uh other comments questions
representative
um i agree with what was previously said
and although we're not voting on the
amendment i i wouldn't move to adopt the
amendment because it had problems as
thank you and i i agree i also
let initially liked the idea of the
amendment but it it is was not as well
thought through as it should have been
and i would recommend the constituent
simply apply to the board for license
which he should have done earlier
all right any other comments questions
seeing none the motion is itl on senate
bill 224 and the clerk can call the rule
representative lucas yes
representative mirner yes representative
plett yes yes representative pearson
yes representative folsom yes
representative at lake grove yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative center
nostalgia yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows yes president
faulkner yes representative grota votes
yes representative gormallo yes and the
chair
yes 19 to zero right where we should be
okay
on that note does anyone object to
consent
okay
we haven't done that yet no 382 is
telehealth yes
i want to do this once i have an
amendment so
senate bill 333 i had an amendment which
i thought was here
and you have it yeah
okay
amendment
i have this is a marsh amendment for
senate bill 333
yes there's there's a i have an
amendment
oh
okay
that's going to be interesting
senate bill 333
and i thought i had copies of it
and i that i brought over dan would you
check the table and see if it's there
because i couldn't find them
yes
i thought
[Music]
oh
three two three
which is a one line amendment
that says delete section two
1594.
[Music]
okay
this build delete section two which is
what which was added by the senate
and that's the section that all the
other case managers are upset about
the situation is there are about six
different types of case managers
the people who have been pushing for
this
bill
is
one type they deal with
medicaid with
home care
for nursing home eligible people it's
probably the largest group of case
managers but it's not the only one
the other
groups deal with developmentally
disabled or private services
and
and they do not
appreciate
having their having the description of
one
branch of case managers
be the
definition in statute
and so
what
what this does is essentially delete the
senate amendment and brings it back to
the
as introduced status
which all of the other groups looked at
and decided to ignore
it so it was only when the senate
amendment was passed that they came out
and said wait a minute you're
you're doing it to us and we don't don't
really want it
um
so that's
one solution to the issue
and
i will
welcome comments rep representative
blackist you wish to speak to your
second um just briefly as uh and i think
is where we're going but
uh
looking at the marsh amendment it
appears that it also uh deletes section
two but does some other things so i'd
like to
so if we adopted it uh it would do that
part and other things and so as i'm sure
represent marshall's ready i'd like to
hear what the difference yeah well i
will i will just mention that the senate
has agreed to
at least from i have been assured that
they agree to my amendment the marsh
amendment incorporates some language
that was offered in the senate and not
chosen
and they would not approve of it
at least that's my understanding thank
you
uh representative marsh you wish to
speak uh thank you i i have to admit
that when we had the hearing for this
bill it was distinctly unclear what was
going on
we heard further uh information at
health and human services oversight last
friday when we heard testimony from the
division of long-term supports and
services bureau of developmental
services the issue is that there are
more parties involved than the house and
the senate there's also the federal
government turns out that the federal
government
passed the deficit reduction act of 2005
which required a number of things one
thing which we did hear about was that
conflict case management be provided we
heard about that in the testimony but
they also adopted a rule uh that
required that there be only one case
manager at a time for medicaid providers
and the reason why was because they were
receiving multiple
bills for services some of which may or
may not have been provided
the state of new hampshire is currently
under
a
corrective action plan which must be
implemented by next june to provide two
things one of which is conflict-free
case management we heard about that but
the second was to fully implement the
single case manager provision of the
1915 c waiver program and if we fail to
comply with that our federal medicaid
money is substantially at risk and they
don't need to remind people that that is
an awful lot of money
the
issue that adopting either the maguire
amendment or what we heard in as
was brought to us from the senate is
that it can it confuses the definitions
of home health providers with uh case
managers which are in the eyes of cms
two separate entities
and the federal government wants those
to be clearly distinct so that the case
managers are supervising and ensuring
that the services that are contracted
for are actually provided
i i will unfortunately have to vote
against your amendment uh and put forth
my amendment as an alternative because i
think that's the only way we can be
that's interesting
uh yes my copies of my men are on the
table buried up under more
more recent
paperwork
um
yeah represent pearson thank you i
um health and human services oversight
committee is
something that is charged with looking
at
this giant blend of the federal
government's
gigantic hand on what we do
and i i know for a fact that they take
that job extraordinarily seriously so
i'm i'm concerned that what was revealed
in the health and human services
oversight meeting
um
really does need to be taken into
account and i'm not entirely sure how
that how we do that so i'm i'll be
looking for additional
discussion in reference to to that i
know representative marsh was there i i
yes
larkis
thank you um do we have any idea of why
the uh senate is opposed to uh what
representative marsh is proposing is it
gonna do something they don't like that
we know or
i believe i represent mars do you know
the
my my
contacts with the senate from which i
would answer that question are currently
not inclined to speak to me on subject
for other reasons
okay well i would suggest that it may
have been due to the opposition of the
other groups of case managers
who didn't want
the medicaid definition
imposed as the only type of case manager
because there are other types including
private pay that do not have to follow
these federal rules
and so
i would
i would consider your amendment as if
you were to say that case management
agencies for the purposes of a home and
community based care
must meet these requirements
i would be willing to do that but not
for to save for a home and
community-based care but for
the purposes of enrollment in the
medicaid program uh but but if that's
acceptable for you i'll be glad to get
an other amendment and we can recess
this to later i think that would solve
the issue
thank you i will do that okay we will
we will
we will recess senate bill 333
and get a better
amendment that addresses the real issues
what else have we got
um
that we had this morning
oh wait that's been killed
we did we deleted the bill
all right uh senate bill 450 the
prescription drug affordability board
representative lucas you have an
amendment do you have a motion i do um
i'd like to move interim study on this
bill
all right breakfast seconded by
representative allegro
and
do you should speak to your motion i do
um
first this is related to um not
identical but related to house bill
1566 on the prescription drug drug
affordability board which we
i think this amendment
may fix some of the concerns
certainly
around well actually it doesn't it with
it it could be
the bill actually has some
issues around the fees and it's
internally inconsistent but i think just
trying to amend that right now
wouldn't uh take care of everything um
i mean i have concerns that
it has very broad exemptions from 91a i
understand that it does deal with
information private proprietary
information
that does need to be kept
um you know not made public
um but
i think we need to look at it and figure
out whether all of its deliberations
really
should be hidden from the public other
than the final decisions i have a real
problem with that
and then the other thing is um
and i don't know if there's
is a sense of being entirely good or bad
but
well it's true it's not a
price fixing bill
or law it's a law now
but um
it kind of sort of is in that
if they're not able to negotiate a price
with suppliers that meets the board's um
desires then
they can say the state won't be able to
buy certain things
and you know even if the doctor of the
patient's doctor thinks that's the best
thing for them
and um you know i have some concerns
about that as well and some other things
so i think
you know really uh studying this is
something we should do for both of those
bills thanks
okay representative
do you wish to speak to your second
briefly i remember what a quagmire the
debate on the house bill turned into and
that their if i recall was broad
consensus that it would benefit from
some additional study
thank you representative marsh
uh yes thank you i cannot support this
motion i believe this bill ought to pass
first of all as far as 91a is concerned
i serve on the prescription drug
affordability board its meetings are
public uh they had one this afternoon
and i believe that they are viewable
online except when you're in the middle
of an executive session of the edna
committee so i'll have to have them let
them catch me up on what happened this
afternoon
regarding the fees i think it is quite
evident that when you look at the whole
statute that the board is capable of
waiving fees such that they do not go
over 125 percent in compliance with this
amendment and i gave that language uh to
my colleague to my right to read to the
committee during the testimony as i was
a sponsor the bill and not able to do so
myself
third as far as price fixing
or denying people access to drugs is
concerned that's not what this is about
this this committee is about providing
transparency uh to make reports as to
what are the most rapidly increasing
drug costs both in individual and
aggregate
to people in public health plans
including our legislative insurance plan
in the state of new hampshire
that actually will benefit all citizens
and not just those involved in the plans
because
the prices tend to increase in parallel
uh no matter what your your insurance
might be so i think this is something
that our public very much wants us to be
involved in they very much want to see
less expensive prescription drugs and
they very much want to see transparency
and therefore i think the spill ought to
pass
representative grotto and then like
thank you um
i don't believe that this bill has the
market control that people
are claiming to say that it does and i
do believe that the purpose of it is to
identify
what is causing the increase in drugs
and prescription drugs in new hampshire
it doesn't really say
that the board doesn't have the
authority to do any kind of price
negotiations but i do i am concerned
about some of the language in the bill
and i hate to do this but i'm just
wondering if we can
if we're if someone's willing to work on
the amendment that had that involved the
125 percent
there were a couple of issues that we
had as as a committee
that were brought up that i felt would
be readily fixed
if we send an amendment in and i don't
know how i don't know what what yes i
as i recall
the discussion senator sherman said just
delete the
yes they were quickly
the minimum 500 fee
and leave the 125 there which would
solve at least that issue
there were two there were two things let
me see if i can quickly put my finger on
them sorry
and there was an rsa yesterday there was
an rsa that was in it that was
so i don't know if that would change
and i do believe that this
these amendments addressed many of the
concerns that we had when we originally
discussed this bill
in committee
on that lovely afternoon
okay well the the other bill was not
this is not identical to the bill that
we discussed it merely deals with the
same statutes
any other comments or questions
representative
thank you um
well it may not be you know the intent
of the current board
to
prevent people from getting medicines
that their doctor may think they should
get
as i read 126 bb it explicitly gives the
board that authority
and we don't know who's going to be in
it in the future
i have a question for representative
lekkis yes is that current statute
what you just said is that i mean does
that exist right now this this bill
doesn't do that they can already do that
right now this is the current statute
yes but i have various concerns about
the bill and i think studying
this and what was in the the 1566
um you know would be good to good to
any other comments representative
pearson thank you madam chair i'm i'm
just looking through what's i don't
really care what what theoretically is
going to happen i got to look at what
the with the four pages of stuff that's
in front of me right now is
um
what what i see here is i see a re you
know alternates to a board which is
something we've done to all kinds of
boards on oplc that's fine
um
a minor
clarification on two definitions
i certainly have a problem with the of
not less than 500 assessed line i
that's i can't believe they put that in
there that that could definitely come
out
but this doesn't this board exists it
doesn't eliminate the board it doesn't
stop the board from continuing to
function right now it really doesn't
change some of the concerns that were
mentioned because those exist right now
the board is functioning they met today
so
i'm trying to see what this senate bill
really does and all i'm looking at is is
two minor definition changes adding
alternates to a board
and
it adds two typos it adds an
unclassified employee employee at
appointed by and serve at the pleasure
of the board
and
okay
this doesn't repeal the board
it doesn't stop what they're currently
doing it doesn't change the 91a parts so
i appreciate the discussion and
reference to those and those are things
that could certainly be addressed at
some point but they're not in here
that's not what we're reading so
um i mean
as it as this exists now with no
amendment no this i i won't support this
but i think that this can be
if we can fix a couple of things that
have been discussed i
represent thank you representative plett
just a question there was a reference to
senate bill 540 we're talking 450
yes i apologize for my um being less
dixie
yes this is senate bill 450
that we are discussing
okay the motion is interim study by
representative lackas
on senate bill 450 and the clerk can
call the role
oh yes that's me i'm sorry
representative mirner yes representative
yes
representative folsom yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative yes representative santon
estazo yes representative goalie
no representative schuett
no representative marsh no
representative fellows no representative
no
representative vote snow representative
gormallo no
and the chair
yes so it's you're back to ten to nine
all right
madam chair i would like to file a
minority report
all right thank you that's good to know
i guess this will not go on consent then
and your motion will be
but
it'll just be a tough motion it has a
typo
okay that's that one
and
then the bill 333 we're awaiting a
senate bill to 382
which is the telehealth licensing
uh representative blackish you have a
motion
i think uh i think uh representative
santana
was oh
pardon me i wrote it down wrong
representative times and decisions
emotion uh yeah move uh
itl for senate bill 382 and all second
all right do we should speak to your
motion
yeah uh the bill uh prohibits telehealth
services to residents of new hampshire
from providers out of state that are
unlicensed by new hampshire
since this
practice is already occurring
if we were going to put this prohibition
in then
they would
you know
take care away from patients that are
currently receiving it
and telehealth is going to be a growing
industry so i think we should try to
work to
support it instead of make it more
difficult
thank you representative
uh thank you and uh
so executive director of oplc argued
that uh in current law
even though it's not explicit it's
probably
not legal for a doctor out of state to
practice doing telehealth to new
hampshire
without a license i mean that may or may
not be true i asked for some case law on
that and i didn't get anything
um i think that you know we're gonna be
moving more and more to telehealth and i
think requiring
every doctor who might provide that
service to
a patient another state to in effect
have to get licensed in every other
state potentially all other states where
they might potentially have a
patient i think is
is nonsense i mean it doesn't make any
sense
they're licensed in their home state
and this idea that we don't trust other
states for this sort of thing is uh
especially for things that are are
regulated and controlled you know to the
extent of being a physician i think is
uh is
doesn't make any sense
i mean if anything i'd want to offer an
amendment that would explicitly say that
a doctor licensed in any state could
practice through telehealth to anyone in
the united states but i wasn't going to
introduce something like this at this
late point so
that's why i support an ital on this and
see what we can do in the future
representative marsh uh thank you i
cannot support this motion and instead
feel that senate bill 382 ought to pass
there are two situations here to
consider first of all there are the
states that have adopted the interstate
compact on the licensure of physicians
and there are those that have not the
state of massachusetts says not and that
is somewhat problematic but in those
states that participate in the compact
it is clearly defined that the site of
service is the location of the patient
and that will govern not only whether
the the
care is licensed to occur but it also
governs things like malpractice law what
courts things get settled in if
something untoward should happen
and what jurisdiction disciplinary
actions might occur in
in states that are not participants in
the interstate compact which would
include the state of massachusetts that
would be undefined if we allow
practice
to not be defined as the patient
physically being in new hampshire being
practiced in new hampshire which is what
as oplc testified is what's normally
been considered to be the case for some
time but it's not currently in statute
due to the rapid expansion of telehealth
we really need to define this or we are
going to end up sooner or later to have
cases where
patients have no idea uh
what courts have jurisdiction over
malpractice which may occur uh double
jeopardy may very well happen uh you may
get conflicting judgments and it will be
an absolute nightmare to sort out so i
believe that this bill truly ought to
pass thank you
thank you other other comments
representative lackas
yeah the only other thing is i'll say is
that
i've heard some concern
about uh
you know if there are complaints um
you know what would new hampshire do and
they
you know the the doctor is going to be
licensed in the state of residence and
you know as i'm sure happens in a lot of
cases the complaint can be passed on to
them and then they can deal with the
doctor in whichever way they they would
okay representative grota and then
allegra
as i enter as i have am looking at my
notes what i have is that this bill
clarifies what's existing in statute so
basically what constitutes practice in
new hampshire at what laws pertaining
pertain to licensing
so i don't really understand
what
the resistance is to this bill
i haven't been there's anything that
i've heard
from anyone
who says that this is going to
limit
access
or
um
cause
you know people that are
not
who are traveling from getting care i
don't understand what maybe perhaps you
can explain that to me representative
lucas
sure um i know of people who have gotten
treatment through telehealth directly
from doctors in other states and
as the executive director said that may
or may not actually be illegal
um you know in general i'd rather have
law be settled
but
i know people have it has served some
people quite well and i'm just not
willing to make it explicitly illegal
and
yes i agree we need to clarify this but
i'm not going to move in the direction
of prohibiting it
representative pearson
thank you madam chair the you know
politics loves hypocrisy so i'm gonna
i'm gonna have to think
i have a general question here if we are
not we meaning
several of us are not in favor
of compacts
as a general rule then our only other
alternative is reciprocity
okay otherwise we're an island
so starting on line 11 i'm reading about
reciprocity agreements all over the
place the oplc shall issue a license
for those that are in good standing of
their other state
that this is the alternative
to
a compact which is reciprocity so
i can't i can't be against both i've got
to be in favor of one or the other and
so it's either it's either
or you can be in favor of both but but
you can't be in favor of none because
otherwise we become an island
and new hampshire is entirely too small
to be an island
this is not a compact this is a
reciprocity
deal
as
representatives
telehealth isn't a is a is moving
the field of that the technology of that
is moving far more rapid than this
legislature moves so
i think that we're already behind the
eight ball in some ways
and if if we're okay with the concept of
this
and we don't like compacts our only
other option is reciprocity
so help me out if i'm missing something
here
sure no i understand that um
oh thank thank you um sorry for jumping
the gun um
i don't i i don't completely have an
opposition to part two part one i do
and what i'm suggesting is that um
for occupational licensing and certainly
cert especially in certain areas that
where there's uh
there tends to be you know significant
regulation all states
that it should be treated like a
driver's license and not require
reciprocity that's my position
and i know that's not in this bill and
it was just
that's something that i might consider
uh introducing the future and i think it
wasn't it wasn't
appropriate to try and introduce an
amendment to this thing to do that at
this point because that would need a
full public hearing and everything
president pearson for follow-up thank
you you know just looking at line 15
shall issue licenses i mean it's
almost
it's not quite direct recognition but
man is it close i mean this isn't even a
should
it's a shell
representative marsh
uh yes we recently got a handout from
our researcher about licensing
requirements from various states and i
will point out to the committee that if
you examine that uh document you will
see that the qualifications for lights
insure amongst the various states very
significantly with new hampshire being
amongst the highest in requiring
educational opportunity education prior
to issuing a license so in fact what you
are doing is creating a back door around
what the legislature has long adopted
for requirements for medical licensure
by allowing physicians in other states
who would not meet licensure
requirements in the state of new
hampshire to practice on our citizens
i'm confused
no i i'm against i wanted to add clarity
to the statement that representative
legis made about
trying to create something like driver's
licenses where it can go from one state
to the other i am in favor of the spill
which essentially defines the site of
service as the location where it is
rendered i'm not
opposed the reciprocity part of the
section i think that the language of the
compact is far superior but i cannot
force the state of massachusetts to
adopt the compact
thank you are there any other comments
thank you madam chair i just on the
first part of the bill i'm just thinking
you know if we're talking about
telemedicine
and the provider isn't licensed in new
hampshire
the the person who's receiving those
services may not even know what state
that person is in so how how do you even
find him if there's a malpractice or any
versus bailey
hi i don't know where it fits into this
wild and wacky world of reciprocity and
compacts and everything but isn't there
a
currently or recently a thing where
we're objecting to massachusetts taxing
people that were telecommuting from new
hampshire
as being
no they live there live and work here
even though the employer is there
and therefore we don't have to pay
and i don't know we even know which side
that falls on but it seems
it seems uh
well this is this already been decided
by the state that we're going to support
that position actually this implies it
because it says if you're telecommuting
i mean if you're providing telehealth
services to a patient in new hampshire
that means you're working in new
hampshire and therefore you are not you
do not owe
massachusetts taxes except that you're a
resident of
massachusetts but the employer evidently
as we go back and forth on this like
that
i think the difference there is that
it's a matter of
new hampshire residents versus
massachusetts residents because if you
are a massachusetts resident you all owe
massachusetts taxes on all work
performed anywhere
having been a massachusetts resident i
i also am a refugee
yes
so
yeah it's
it may help a
a new hampshire resident who works for a
massachusetts employer and then does
telehealth but i think that's a a very
minor case in this situation
so
if consistently consistency was to be my
hobgoblin should i be voting yes or no
i don't know
i i wouldn't claim that you have a
little mind
i would like to say that this is one of
the the many things we deal with
where it doesn't really matter
as long as everything goes well
it's only when something bad happens
that you're going to care whether
which states laws apply
because
just you know who to complain to is
if if everything goes well this doesn't
matter if you see some if you call up
somebody like your
i don't know what the name of the the
the website is that gives you viagra
medications and you don't have any
complaints
they may be doing something criminal by
this bill but who but you aren't going
to complain
it's only when something bad happens
that there's going to be a real issue as
okay
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on senate bill 382 and the clerk can
call the rule
representative lucas yes
representative murder yes representative
plett yes representative pearson no
representative folsom yes
represent allegro yes representative
bailey
yes
representative lanzara yes
representative center nostalgia yes
representative goalie
no president stewart
no representative georgie no
representative schmidt no representative
marsh vehemently no representative
fellows no
representative faulkner no
representative grote votes no
representative gore malo no
so it's nine to ten
representative marsh moves ought to pass
is there a second schmidt
is there any further discussion have we
beaten this dead horse i i just want to
commend the chair for a true
understanding of the spill when it
matters is when something bad happens
and then it really matters
okay
all right so it's ought to pass by
representative marsh seconded by
okay this all right on this dead horse
the motion is ought to pass
senate bill 382
okay
representative lucas no
representative murder
oh
representative plett no representative
pearson yes
representative allegro no
representative bailey
no representative lonzara
yes
representative santo nestaso
no representative goalie
yes representative stuart
i believe you skipped representative
folsom but i
guess
oh my gosh i am so sorry but i haven't i
didn't put anything next to her name
representative folsom no
okey-doke i apologize representative
schuett
yes representative georgie
we shall know
representative schmidt
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes representative faulkner yes
represent of ots representative gore
yes
all right um is there going to be a
yes i have one wire before okay and
okay
all right so we have we are waiting for
a
adam chairman we did get an amendment on
277 which i emailed to you and it was
sent to hcs i've not seen that they
brought down copies okay
uh dan could you
excuse me could you see if that
amendment is available
you
okay
right one two
three four
one two
three
let's
we have one two three four five six
seven eight nine
so three through three we are working
waiting for an amendment
277 we have the amendment we think
yes
i believe so it was just
okay
274 which is the one we have not yet to
end um
in 397 where we were kind of
back and forth
so 274
senate bill 274
madam chair move
inexpedient to legislate on 274 and i'll
okay
yes
um 2784 dealt with
project labor agreements
and
the committee heard
testimony that
currently in new hampshire there has
never been a project labor agreement on
any contract put forward by the state
we also heard
from individual contractors
who said that if there was a project
labor agreement that they would not bid
on the contract
i look at it as that's a business's
choice whether or not they decide to bid
and under the conditions of the contract
specifically asked if that was their
choice and they said yes because they
contained a pla
that's a business decision
that's up to them to decide which
contracts they want to bid on no
different than whether they're in
manchester and want to bid on a contract
up in pittsburgh new hampshire whether
it's feasible for them
um so
for those
reasons um i i will not this is just a
solution you know problem insertion
solution in search of a problem that's
not there and i will not
support that and
move itl
okay representative marshall do you wish
to speak to your second yes thank you
madam chair i think it became evident
during the testimony that the definition
of government assisted project in this
bill would apply to uh projects that are
subject to rsa 79e and receiving tax
exemptions which would include the
advanced regenerative manufacturing
institute in manchester which uh the
city of manchester is currently applying
for a 100 million dollar grant
we heard from the mayor and that that
would be most disadvantageous to the
city of manchester both because they
wouldn't receive the funds and because
this would create a great many
really good jobs for the city of
manchester
we
also learned that were we to exclude
that definition from the bill it would
still be problematic because a number of
other grants dealing with department of
transportation projects also require
project labor agreements uh including
the rebuilding american infrastructure
with sustainability and equity grant
program
which is a rather large grant program
and a number of others which i would be
happy to read to the committee if they
are interested i i think that
disadvantaging the state of new
hampshire and competing for federal
funds is distinctly not in the interest
of our citizens and therefore this bill
is exp inexpedient to legislate thank
you
thank you
i'd like to mention that i have an
amendment from senator bradley
that deals with some of those later
issues regarding the definition of who
who would be covered by this bill
that would amend the the first one that
i mentioned but not the other grants
which the department of
uh transportation clearly is a division
of the government and would still be
subject to the limitations under this
bill
thank you but in any event we can't
consider the amendment until
under this motion
representative pearson
since uh since i'm going to do a deep
dive on the on the sword here
um a couple things in my mind
um
and in this
i know this is on video so the new
hampshire municipal association can can
eat this up this is going to be a rare
opportunity that i agree with them
um
in reference to local control i am a
general local control guy
i always have been and
they have some serious concerns in
reference to local control i have
serious serious concerns that this will
shut off federal money to the state of
new hampshire regardless of whether or
not we like what the fred's tack on to
things that is the current reality and i
don't think it's in the interest of the
taxpayers to cut off hundreds of million
dollars of potential federal money for a
plethora of items that occur
we
i will remind the committee that it is
federal law that anyone can bid on a job
any contractor can bid on a job and as i
have a substantial safety background a
lot of these project labor agreements
focus around safety and safety
conditions on jobs
so
we've we've never really
we haven't used these in new hampshire i
don't think we have a problem to to
address with this i think that the
ramifications are substantial
uh and i don't even think they're fully
fully out there i think i think we're
gonna there's more problems with this
than we even realize so
for the for the sake of just doing this
i don't agree with this i think it's
just gonna cause too many problems and
i'm certainly not gonna have the
taxpayers of dairy
have to foot the bill for things that
could have been uh had federal money
matching with them so i'm i'm a solid
now
um i'm little don't quite understand why
if we've never used them then
prohibiting them is going to cause this
disaster to fall in our heads
and and i agree i mean it is a business
decision but uh
i don't think it's appropriate for the
state to uh to mandate them and and it
would still be a business decision
whether a contractor
wanted to make use of apla
even if it were not required by the
thank you
other comments questions representative
schmidt
so the motion is itl yes and
representative pearson just said he's a
solid no
although his argument sounded like he
was a yes
i'm a solid no to this to the idea of
this so i will be voting for the itl
thank you
okay
as exp
the motion is in expediency legislate on
senate bill 274 and the clerk can call
representative lucas yes
yes to itl
i'm sorry
representative mirner
yes representative plett no
representative pearson yes
representative allegro no representative
bailey
representative folmsome
i don't know what it is i'm saying i've
forgotten what i'm supposed to say
are you for itl
emotions can you give me a moment and go
on yes
the motion is it on senate bill
274.
of course sorry
representative santo nestazzo
no
representative goalie
yes everything stuart
yes representing surety we
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representing
fellows yes representative founder yes
representative groat of ocs
representative gormallo yes and the
chair
oh do you want to wait no
it is 12 to 7 then motion passes
okay
that will not be on consent does someone
okay represent
the blackest woman write a minority
report
okay
that one
and
representative marsh we will move
we are back to senate bill 277
and representative marsh moves amendment
1763.
yes madam chair i do and i'll be glad to
explain the difference between this
amendment and representative cuba which
excuse me technical correction the
previous motion on this bill was by
represent bailey adopting amendment 1695
and rather than voting on it we have a
revision to that amendment
by representative marsh we should
probably have voted on the other
you need a motion or do you
we dropped the conversation after the
motion was made before it passed can he
withdraw his motion yes he could
uh i do have some comments before you
withdraw as if that's okay in regards to
it
i have some comments in regard to the
previous amendment
uh just michael ivolkovic
he contacted me in the interim he's
watching it on uh the internet and he
was just pointing out that um
the
the concern is you know potentially you
know
three to six years in the future with
the continuing education requirements
and since this bill is just to
kind of temporarily you know extend the
uh emergency licensure
we could just uh take care of the
problem uh and you know
during another legislative session as
far as making sure the contingent
occasion would be covered okay well
that's more
that's more of a question on
representative marsha's amendment
we are on senate bill 277
the previous motion which we had not yet
voted on
was on amendment 1695 by representative
bailey
yes representative bailey do you wish to
withdraw your motion or do we should
it's not a good question it's not yes
it's not a trick question
you want to vote on a vote
okay
all right so which amendment
so this the amendment that we had the
motion on is amendment 1695
written by representatives
and
representatives yes i i know we're we're
voting on this amendment but it would
help me make the decision if i knew just
what what lines in
representative marsha's amendment differ
it's lines 21 and 22.
but no that's not correct manager or in
the
the in yokobovich's amendment uh lines
12 through 14 and lines 22 to 24 are the
lines that i object to and i'll be glad
to explain what i would propose that we
replace them if you would think that is
an order
uh i have one concern
your amendment specifically addresses
rsa 329 16g
which i believe is the licensing
official physicians
uh you're correct and that's because
that's what we had in the information
that was distributed it would take me
longer to prepare an amendment that
looked at other medical providers
well
i'm not sure i would require every
medical provider
to provide evidence they've met the
physician's continuing education
requirement which is what your bill your
amendment does
but anyway uh the current amendment is
and as i said rep as he said represented
yes
you'd like to just recess it again
foreign
yes i'm
um
i'm certainly not going to accept your
your your amendment because it simply
says medical providers and not
physicians i'm have no problem with
saying physicians shall meet
that requirement but it's
a typical doctor mistake thinking that
you're so right how could i disagree
with that statement
and always illegibly
of course
so madam chair then so if i understand
this right if if representative marsh
was to amend
just part c
on lines 21 and 22 to read a physician
shall be required would that satisfy the
the circumstances we're trying to
find two places 12 does say that not
withstanding any law oh it's up there
it's up there on 12 as well my thought
is that i'll just ask coalesce to strike
pursuant to rsa 329-16g
because they can certainly define which
is the statute and the rules and look
them up for the various medical
providers and the intent here is to
require the applicant to present
evidence uh that does not require that
they actually have met the requirements
that gives the board significant
latitude which i believe is appropriate
in emergency situations
okay
thank you so
we have the motion on the akubovich
amendment which
now that we understand the the marsh
which a different version of which will
be brought forward after we take this
vote if we prefer it are there any other
issues with the yakupovic amendment that
we should discuss while we're
looking at it representation
madam chair yes
representing flat if we were to pass
1695 the yokuba which amendment and then
we were to take up uh representative
marsha's revised amendment would we not
have to
take a vote to reverse the 1695 adoption
second amendment
would supersede the first one
in my committee we had to do just that
right
okay representing goalie you have a
comment
i'm
still
a little confused with this continuing
education um
if you look at the conditions for
licensure on the emergency medic
licensing process
any medical provider previously licensed
in the last three years
how are they going to provide continuing
education if representative lakers could
turn
then i i look at
this is a condition to reactivate their
license
so i i guess my question is why are we
requiring continuing education for
someone who's been out of the service
for three years
how are they going to do that
that's a very good question and i would
like my preferred approach would be to
say that they shall complete
their continuing education within a
shorter period of time than the two
years of the license that representative
marsh has probably has a different
answer yes as a retired physician i can
attest to the fact that many retired
physicians retain an interest in
medicine and continue to
attend lectures or classes and may very
well be able to document that they have
met
the continuing education requirements
although they may not have submitted the
paperwork so that's why i phrased it in
thank you any other comments
questions
massive confusion all around okay
the vote on amendment 16
the motion is ought to pass amendment
1695-h
may represent blackous uh just briefly
so as i understand what you uh told
representative plett
if we adopt this amendment and then uh
we do get an amendment we find
acceptable
from representative marsh and we adopt
that it supersedes it so it'd be fine i
mean so i'm thinking about
voting yes on this one and if the other
one looks good i vote yes on that as
well it would be okay is that correct
yes that's my plan also thank you i
think that this amendment deals with a
lot of the issues we had with the the
bill
and so i would recommend that we support
this amendment and then
specifically consider a second amendment
that would address the continuing
education issue representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i too will
support the amendment um
we've been working
under this language for the last year
and there has been no problems and
that's all this is doing is extending
this basically
another year
and i feel comfortable with that we're
not doing
going beyond
thank you any other comments
okay so the
the motion
is the 1695 amendment to senate bill 277
representative lucas yes representative
mirner yes representative plett
yes representative pearson yes
representative folmsome yes
representative allegro yes mr
representative bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie
yes representative stewart
yes repeat mgod
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh no
representative fellows
yes
representative faulkner yes
representative cordova yes
representative
carmelo yes and the chair
yes
okay 18 to one motion passes
at 18 to 1 the amendment is adopted it's
available for
further
amendment and representative marsh
you're going to get something that
addresses i already submitted it we'll
see how long it takes though okay
okay the other bill we have what other
bills do we have 397
[Music]
i think we need to take a break while
we're getting these amendments
and then three two three with the other
one
and we never give the vote on this
we didn't vote on that either because
now we ended up with but and there was
emotion we had the same problem
i think we take a break yeah come back
382.
now i admit my hearing is not what it
used to be
no it's 13 to 6.
for otp
um
let's look at the the list i just had a
question about it yeah 13 to 6 uh okay
from marshalls i got 11 to eight
madam chair we now have the amendment to
senate bill 333 okay
which i will email to you
what's that yes for carol we just got
the amendment to 333. excellent make
good make sure you get some copies and
no
her name do i have that no you're
yes
we have three bills
yet to uh
to vote on
senate bill 277 we have passed the
yokubovich amendment
and representative marshall's getting
another amendment do we have that yet
okay
all right then we will hold off on
dealing with that
because it it's a serious issue
so they get five minutes left they close
at five don't they
ols
no i they will stay as long as we're
here and i think we're close enough to
the finish line that i'd rather not come
okay so representative goalie you have a
motion
yes madam chair i move reconsideration
on the out to pass as amended motion on
senate bill 397
okay
this is reconsideration
all right so the action is that if we
vote yes on reconsideration
so
um
does anyone wish to speak on
reconsideration
okay i guess not that's pretty
self-explanatory
in that case the clerk can call the role
representative lucas yes representative
murder yes representative plett yes
representative pearson yes representing
folsom yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lanzara yes
representative santorostazo yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative zod
around representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes yes representative faulkner yes
representative groeder votes yes
representative gormallo
yes and the chair yes
19 to zero
okay so we are reconsidering our vote
of ought to pass with the pearson
amendment on senate bill 397
this leaves the bill consisting of the
mental health compact
and the additional phrase on the
[Music]
children placement of children but not
the
compact on placement of children
that is that what everyone understands
the vote to be
okay is there any discussion
further discussion isn't that what it
was
yes yes
the motion failed so we we have voted to
reconsider so now we're going to do it
again and hopefully some people have
that's the term
that's it have reconsidered exactly
considered it
very good so
we don't have a motion or a second
though on that we can on the on the uh
well look we've already had the motion
it was made by representative pearson i
got it never mind i have to get another
piece and judy seconded
okay just a second okay
so does any does anyone need any further
debate before we move to the vote
all right seeing none
just so i understand this is otp a where
the a is the pearson amendment correct
thank you
okay
if you're thoroughly confused
representative brody you can
you could you can get it it's a clean
slate you don't have to vote the same i
just want to make sure that we don't
vote the same way or else we'll be here
until
long time exactly sb 397 okay so
representative lucas
uh i guess yes
okey dokey representative
mirner
yes
representative
plett wait
representative pearson yes
representative folmson
yes representative allegro no
representative
bailey
could you come back to me i want to read
them again okay representative lonzara
yes representative santon estazo
yes
representative goalie
yes representative schuett
yes
representative marsh no
representative fellows
yes
representative faulkner
yes representative grotto votes yes
representative gormallo yes
and the chair representative bailey
representative bailey
yes
representative
and the chair no
no okay so it's 16 to 3 the motion
passes
otpa with house senate bill i mean
amendment 1759 madam chair i'd like to
um
if you've got
you got one but i would like to
elaborate well i suspect we will differ
for different reasons uh you are i i
suspect that to be the case also
so i think would probably be better if
you wrote it
thank you i've already written it
and your emotion will be
my emotion will be ought to pass for the
and what certainly wouldn't be my
recommendation what would and what would
that be what would that amendment number
okie dokie all right
one down
and we don't have quite have the
all right so
um
have we voted on either amendment
no
okay no we didn't make the same problem
as
we have emotion by you a second by lucas
okay
um
in that case i think we need to
continue the debate and decide what to
do
yes
my the amendment that i that we that we
are under consideration at the moment
which is amendment number
simply adds the explicit requirement
that the case management providers be
licensed
it deletes any definition of case
management
and
as introduced position which nobody
cared about or nobody cared enough about
to object
so
so i think that's a
representative pearson thank you um but
you know going to the wayback machine
here a little bit just to
as to what we talked about
earlier
um
if i understand this correctly
the marsh amendment contains language
that the senate has already rejected
that is correct so your amendment
restores this bill
to its as
filed
state
which eliminates the objections from all
the other case managers which which we
we heard in in testimony so
just so that uh we can all refresh
ourselves as to exactly what's before us
that's thank you for that
okay
any other comments questions just
concerns
okay
what yes representative grota so during
this testimony there seemed to be
a disagreement between the case
management
service providers
and the home care providers
and health and human services
and i don't know how this amendment
resolves that
it eliminates
the home care providers
it does not add a definition of case
managers
it simply says that that they are to be
licensed
as they have been for the last 20 odd
years
it is
probably not the best result
because there are other issues that need
to be considered
but we don't have enough information and
we don't have enough time to do it
um
so
i think just establishing that yes they
need to be
licensed because i don't know why
hhs decided after 20 odd years of
licensing them
including that they don't have any
statutory authority to license them so
i'm concerned about
what hhs is thinking
and also and what their intentions are
and i do not want to speculate on them
because
that's not what we do and so i think
just saying yes we think these people
these organizations need to be licensed
do it the way you have been doing it
seems like the right step to take now
any additional steps that need to be
i said that
next year
because we only have
i mean i was extremely disappointed at
the hearing that no that hhs wasn't
explaining their point of view
thank you madam chair
i was
unable to
be here for that hearing and i guess i
just have a question as to
what happens if we don't make this
change now
are we able to interim study this
because this appears to me this is where
this should go this isn't a problem
that's going to be solved today it's
an ongoing issue that's been going on
and
it needs to be dove into a lot deeper
than what we've had time to do um so i'm
just
wondering for myself
whether or not
this has to go through
this year or can we intro really interim
study this and do the work that should
i don't know i agree with you that the
whole topic needs to be looked at but
i'm not sure we're the right people to
do it because it's mostly tangled up
with
not so much with licensing as with
medicaid
and
we don't
we'd rather not get involved
but if the original impetus for the bill
was a statement by hhs that they don't
have the authority to license these
organizations
and they don't come to defend that here
i think i'm
i'd like to just say yes we want to
license them
and let
the other issues be dealt with by hhs
for one
and uh financed by the other
it
that's my preference but if you i'm sure
you could see it differently
representative marsh yes i'll point out
to everyone that the state of new
hampshire is under a deadline from the
federal government to come into
compliance by this june and putting this
off until next year is not going to
solve the problem and the last thing we
want is for the state of new hampshire
to have to fund the dd program out of
state funds and no longer be eligible
for medicaid dollars to do so
yes i don't disagree that we don't want
to fund that program
but
if it isn't defined statute now isn't it
within their rules to in their authority
to make rules on it
i
i mean we had the whole medicaid program
under the commissioner of hhs's ruling
broad rulemaking authority
so i i
understand that they have tremendously
wide rule making authority on that they
do have tremendously wide rule making
authority but i do not think that they
have the authority to suddenly license
people without some statutory authority
to do so and the federal government is
requiring them to license these
providers well representative marshall
trouble with this is this doesn't
address the dd providers
they are not included in this bill
and they've they were here testifying to
say that well we're licensed under a
different statute
and
you know i i don't disagree with you
that they ought to be but i don't
believe that
um
that this bill is what's going to solve
that issue
i think this version of the bill will
not solve the issue which is why i have
my amendment which i gave to you
i don't believe that
your amendment either
solves the issue of the dd
providers
they're licensed under 171
or not licensed under 171. as the case
the case managers are not actually
providers they are people that
coordinate care and the federal
government began making a distinction
between the two uh with the deficit
reduction act of 2005 which is i believe
the original event that started the
well
so why on earth don't we have didn't we
have a bill originally to address that i
mean this is
this is really i would rather amend the
bill so there's very little to it and
then be the up the senate and committee
of conference
i don't want to keep adding
stuff on rumors and hearsay
i i don't think that the testimony of
the at hhs oversight was rumors and
hearsay and i agree with you that health
and human services could bring their
bills
in a more
timely manner and in a more divided
manner so they could be properly
considered by the legislature
well yeah that's beyond my control
indeed and the fact that the senate has
already considered this and rejected it
says
it's a waste of time for us to to add it
because
they've already said no we don't want to
do that
regardless of what hhs said
if if we add that amendment my concern
is that the senate will say you know we
don't care let it let it die
if it feels
which i understand is going to happen
without even a committee a conference
representative goalie
thank you manager and
if we amend this
and the senate decides to go to
committee conference
deadline for the committee conference is
the end of may
and goes forward and whether it gets
signed or not this doesn't take effect
until 60 days after that we're looking
um so i i think that's another issue
there that we we're talking about when
you talk about deadlines and this needs
to be implemented right away it's not
going to be implemented right away it's
a ways off
is in section that it's section two that
has the deadline
section one just says keep doing what
you've been doing
let me note with no particular deadline
anyone else want to get in on this
representative schuett
thank you i have a genuine question um
we know that
you've said several times that the
senate rejected
the amendment i believe it was senator
carson's originally
and representative marsh has put a house
note on it
did
did the senate have the information
about the differentiation from cms at
the time that they rejected that
i don't know for sure they did have the
information from hhs
which was the letter that said there's
these different types of case managers
including for example the dd is under
you know
they're covered under this section or
that section
or the programs are under such sections
and they had that information
i don't know if they had any other
it's a it's questionable in my mind as
to
what criteria they made their decision
[Laughter]
and we may not be able to change that
uh i'm not sure i'm going to answer what
they had in mind representative pearson
thank you
madam chair rep so the mcguire amendment
here the 1694-h which really just
brings it back to part one what does
part one solve
it solves the declaration of
hhs that they do not have statutory
authority to license case managers in
the medicaid
home care market
and that this will then give them that
authority correct
that's it
it doesn't address the deeper issues
which i'm sure will come back to haunt
no
anyone else representative grota
so if this amendment
addresses the immediate problem that we
have with licensing
and
given the time constraints i'm thinking
that that's the best this committee
could do
this might be the best compromise even
though
it's not the right compromise
correct
i would agree with that assessment
it's a it's a quick fix
to a problem that is
deeper than we have time to solve and i
and with all due respect to
representative goalie i'm not sure we're
so
so that's my take on it anyone else
representative blackis yeah and as to
the concerns of the 60 days i don't know
but i would hope that if the bills
actually
been passed and signed that
the 60 days would not get you know
medicare to decide they're going to cut
us off because of that but what do i
okay anyone else
all right see yes representative fellows
so i i'm just trying to understand this
so if we adopt
the amendment
that defines case management service
providers and it says that they're they
don't deliver direct services they're
just making the arrangements
correct no that's the marsh amendment
that does that my amendment deletes the
definition
okay because it is
probably correct for the
home and community based care case
management providers that deal with the
medicaid program but it is not correct
for people who in other for case
managers in other situations so
when because you're only deleting
two
you're not changing
section one
where there's a reference to case
management service providers so there's
not really a depth is there definition
no
so they they can just deal with it or
sure hope so
okay but we're not here if they've been
they have this lot this particular
section has not been changed and the
case management agencies have been
providing these services and
arrangements and so forth they're
generally conflict-free as it turns out
and so
why hhs decided they can't quite license
them anymore
they've been doing it for almost three
all right
anyone else
all right seeing none
the motion is ought to pass amendment
1694 to senate bill 333
representative lucas yes
representative mirner yes representative
plett yes representative pearson yes
represented informed some yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
blansara yes representative santo nostal
yes apparently
yes
marsh
no
representative fellows yes
representative faulkner
yes european growth of ocs
representative gormallo yes
and the chair
yes eighteen to one motion
okay the motion passes 18 to 1.
madam chair i object to consent and
we haven't done the ought to pass yet
okay but i'm sorry that's okay but we
know that's kevin i am not we'll do that
okay the motion
i then move ought to pass with amendment
and
is there a second
okay i'm not going to say any more rep
represent pearson do you wish to speak
absolutely not
all right any does anyone wish to speak
representative goalie
thank you madam chair
i will support this motion um
and i'm hoping
this is a temporary fix and that health
and human services comes back with a
long-term solution to this problem and
that the solution is not brought to this
committee but to the appropriate
committee
to decide
thank you very much representative
goalie i will entirely agree with you on
that
yes
thank you representative goalie from
yeah
it's
a bit of a mess
okay anyone else
okay the motion is ought to pass with
the amendment
and the clerk can call the rule
representative lucas yes representative
berner yes representative klett yes
rebellion pearson yes representative
fulmsum yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative center
nostalgia yes representative goalie
yes
representative jody we shall
representative schmidt
yes president of marsh
no
representative fellows yes
representative faulkner yes
representative grota votes yes
representative gormallo
yes and the chair
yes eighteen to one
and we have we have and we will have a
minority report so this will go on to
the
and your motion will be representative
harsh
okay
so that was 18 one
and what else do we have left
277 i think
yes just technically should that should
the motion not be ipo no no he wants to
pass it with a different amendment
okay so he doesn't have to ideal and
then
no
yep
okay so that leaves us with one bill
still with us
senate bill 277
and where did we leave off
well we passed 1695 d we passed the
jacobovic amendment 18 to 1. and oh yes
and representative marsh was getting
another amendment that would
clarify sections of that amendment okay
correct
all right so representative marshall you
have that amendment uh ols has not yet
sent it to me i'm willing to let the
debate go forward because i think i can
see where this is going and i'll
okay well
what is
all right we'll let the day go forward
and i will ask you to present the
specific areas you are are recommending
give me a minute to get my papers i'm
apologizing okay no trouble we're
juggling a lot of things we're juggling
a lot of papers
yes
representative marsh can i ask him a
question
what's up representative marsh he's
getting his act together is ols gonna
send you the amendment that's what they
told me okay you know why that's okay
are you sure he said the amendment's
upstairs is going to grab it uh it
hasn't come in my email but maybe he got
one i don't know
it could be a different one okay thank
you representative marsh explain the
concerns
adam chair
yes did we do 225 was it
we did that this morning that was the
auctioneer one yes that was the one that
you motioned
okay i i will speak uh using amendment
number 1763h which i asked ols to base
this off of
um
and the only difference between this
amendment and the forthcoming one is on
line 13 and line 22
i asked them to strike pursuant to
rsa 3 29 16 g as the chair requested and
change that to saying pursuant to the
applicable statute
um
if they put in the numbers that would be
even better but i doubt they'll do that
in short order
the the issue is a very straightforward
one uh and that regards whether the
people we are actually licensing are
actually qualified and whether we are
putting our citizens at risk and as a as
i said if you look at the cycles of
licensure for physicians which is the
example i know best
you could do all of your continuing
medical education in the last cycle that
you actually did education in the first
year leaving the second year with no
cmas you could then do the following
cycle doing no cmes which is two more
years your license lapses you then have
three years to apply for one of these
licenses that makes six years so far and
it's two more years before you are
required to present evidence of cme
for your licensure so conceivably a
physician would be continuing to
practice without having done any
education for eight years i believe
the the amendment simply requires the
provider to present evidence that
they're concurrent with continuing
education it doesn't require the board
to actually require them to be current
it just requires them to present
evidence so then the board can make an
informed and reasonable decision on a
thank you i think that
is there any other discussion
representative platt yes the use
referred uh representative marsh to a
specific rsa dealing with physicians in
two places you struck them in both did
you
yes
yes i asked them to replace that with
the to the applicable statutes because i
know it's a different statute for nurse
practitioners for physician assistants
for whatever and
i'm not capable of looking up all the
statutes while also debating bills here
in the committee
yes why not
thank you
any other comments representative
pearson
no um you know just just thinking back
to some you know i'm my medical license
is in a different area so it's uh for
the department of safety
um but i agree with representative marsh
in the way that
the continuing education hours work
in that in that world is the same and
you can
what what he's describing as a timeline
is is extraordinarily plausible it's
it's it's actually quite easy so
i agree that having um
a physician out of any
or any medical provider really that's
out of continuing education for that
length of time i mean that's
i spent seven years in college you know
then we're i got two degrees we're
talking about eight years of of ces
which is just really you know the
threshold is is relatively minor when it
comes to continuing education but that
puts you out of the field for for so
long that it
i i agree with him that it's an
unacceptable duration of time
madam chair the amendment number is 1773
h
okay
i'm waiting to see who's going to come
i know one or two reps that would love
to have that number i'll bet
okay
so
at this point we've already adopted the
cuba vich amendment year moving
amendment 1773
which is being yes i am thank you
so further discussion
that's right and we're proud supporters
i think i'd
rather make paper than uh
expensive power yes and represent like
us
uh yes i mean this was for um
is granted under you know emergency and
it's uh going to end
i think um
what was the the ending date on this i
apologize but it's it's not that long
and so i don't
i don't see a need to do this i mean if
it was the original
going out to 2024
i might see a stronger argument but uh
well this also would a lie allow
in a future emergency
emergency license to be issued
bless you and um
that is you know
under the circumstances we might want to
dig up
retired doctors or nurses or physical
therapists or whatever
and
having them be
having them be under this amendment
would make some sense or even retired
emts
i agree with the chair i'm far more
concerned about the effects of a future
emergency or some other incident going
forward okay thank you representative
blackis
actually i would see that argument on
the other side because if we really have
an emergency and we need medical
people and things are disrupted i don't
think we'd want to have to
prevent them from helping out just
because they're waiting on some
training which may or may not be
available under the emergency
okay
anyone else
what's up
okay any other comments questions
all right the motion is to adopt
amendment 1773
to senate bill 277
and the clerk can call the role
representative lucas no representative
mirner
yes representative plett no
representative pearson yes
representative fulmson
representative allegro
representative bailey
representative lanzara
representative marsh
representative fellows yes
representative
yes
representative grotto votes yes
yes okay one two three
it is thirteen to six
the amendment passes all right
and to representative legacy's concern
if it's that serious an emergency i
don't think anybody's going to be
okay
so
herpes
the amendment is adopted
okay
this
okay it do you wish to speak to your
motion
okay representative grota
okay
oh i don't have any i'm so sorry no i
almost started the role no
okay
wish to speak on this
test
anyone else
okay seeing none
the motion is ought to pass with
amendment the clerk can call the roll
are you all ready this is the last one
of the day
we hope
representative lucas yes representative
mirner
yes representative plett yes
representative pearson yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative center
nostalgia
yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows
yes representative faulkner yes
representative groat of ocs
representative gormallo yes and the
chair yes
19 to 0
excellent finishing on a
on a high note
okay
in that case we'll put that one on
consent
and all all the committee reports are
due
no later than tomorrow
and i'm expecting ones from
representative bailey on senate bill 225
representative shewett on senate bill
pearson on 357.
i'm yeah i've got that one i've written
senate bill 282 representative marsh
i've written 358 representative fellows
on 226
representative pearson on 397.
and oh excuse me and representative
schmidt is doing a minority report on
that doesn't seem right
okay
i'm writing 333
and represent marsh is writing the
one two three
i've only got
to well three minority
okay
representative lekkis
on
verbs in march on 382
whereas in goalie on 274
and representative lekkis is writing a
minority represents santa nissassos on
382 is the minority and this last one is
yes it is
and thank you to all of our substitutes
thank you all thanks for such an easy
day
and